Hunter Biden walks as president Trump
faces 100 years in jail 100 years behind
bars for president Trump as Hunter Biden
given a sweetheart plea deal he's
allowed to walk for everything he's done
for the laptop for everything else that
we've seen over all the past years all
of the headlines all of the data all of
the little pieces of information that'll
come out the text messages the emails
everything we've seen all the pieces of
it the money laundering the influence
peddling firing Ukrainian prosecutors
and it all comes down to Hunter Biden
given a plea deal
for money laundering
and given a slap on the wrist
essentially gets probation will dig into
all of it
for this charge for his lying to the ATF
on a gun charge in Delaware while using
drugs imagine if that happened to any of
us then we want to get into the story of
the Titan submersible hours left to live
uh the people down there though but also
the response to it because it seems like
there's people who are actually rooting
in this case for the ocean and for
people to die while trapped at the
bottom of the ocean potentially within
or under or in some case in in between
parts of the Titanic itself the sunken
wreck and also Riley Gaines testifying
before the United States Senate about
women's role and the trans role of women
in sports but before all that head on
over to castbrew.com by casparu coffee
pick up rise with Roberto Jr Appalachian
Knights joined the cast Brew Coffee Club
you get three bags a month this is the
cultural Endeavor of Tim cast we're
going to be working on getting those
cool in-person spaces to hang out but we
have to do that we have to build it up
first so go to casper.com don't Smack
the microphone like I just did and then
get pick it up you can also get the
Colombian you can also get your French
roast and and also while you're done
that
go to timcast.com click join us become a
member support Tim's work the other Tim
that's Tim Alpha this is Tim Prime if
you will I'm Tim 2.0 and then call in if
you are a member because we are going to
have the members segment coming up at 10
p.m if you're a member you've been in
good standing for six months or you're
at the 25 tier you'll be able to clone
wave a very spicy conversation plan also
while you're at timcast.com you can
download right for now if you're an
Android User the timcast app this app is
still in review for the Google Play
Store and for the Apple store but if you
are an Android User you can actually
download it at timcast.com right now so
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
all this and more Anthony cabassa
Anthony who are you and uh what do you
do thank you so much uh something looks
very different about you Tim you got my
hair done what are you talking about got
my I got my hair done you can't tell
because I also got my beanie done
underneath gotcha that's what it must be
uh hello everyone thanks for having me
here first and foremost to the whole
timcast crew and uh to Tim cast himself
Tim pool rather
um Timothy cast quick quick little plugs
happy birthday my friend Ashley what's
up to the tech telegram gang uh the
extremists of the West and uh producers
armit Sala Marcia who are tuning in Los
Angeles young Republicans and of course
my wife and children back at home my
name is Anthony kobasa I am on the front
lines in Los Angeles California
um and uh I am an independent journalist
I do uh live streaming as well every
morning 9 A.M to 10 30 ish
um uh Pacific time and I have been doing
independent journalism since 2017 cover
the protests the riots the summer of uh
love I think that's what they called it
right
um and then just most recently I've been
covering some of the uh Glendale and
Saticoy parents The Armenian parents out
there that I've been kicking butt
literally and figuratively and then also
the prayer night that I was there with
you Tim 2.0 that's right for that and so
uh yeah very happy to be here thank you
so much awesome my name is Sheamus
Coughlin I make cartoons I'm an animator
I'm also a podcaster so I have a YouTube
channel called Freedom tunes and we're
going to be releasing a video tomorrow
that I think is going to be a lot of fun
it's a meme review where I fix a bunch
of left-wing memes this time for pride
month those are a fan favorite so if you
guys want to go over there subscribe
check that out tomorrow we're also going
to be releasing a 30 minute long version
of that video Behind the paywall a long
extended version so if you want to
become a member go to freedomtunes.com
and sign up for that how you doing
tonight Ian I'm doing fantastic man in
like a fireball welcome back everybody
it's been a few days I think Tim was
feeling a little under the weather yeah
I'm glad you're uh recovered from yeah I
decided to go with my sunglasses in
honor of Jack pesobic who I haven't seen
in a while shout out to Jack the sovik
he's out there somewhere good guys
um thanks for having me probably
sleeping on the job yeah usually he does
sleeping on his pillow I got a lot I
could say about that guy all right I
love that guy we all could hey we also
have uh rep yeah for real yes what's up
guys we are running the show quite well
I feel like uh bear with us Tim ready to
start when you are all right let's do it
let's get into this first story and now
I know a lot of people have probably
seen this of course we haven't been out
on the Tim cast trail of course we've
been on assignment Tim Prime Is On
Assignment Tim 2.0 is here for the time
being Joe Biden continuing his Bay Area
fundraising trip on Tuesday appearing at
Event in San Francisco where he briefly
addressed news of his son Hunter Biden's
plea deal joined by joined by Gavin
Newsom which we definitely have to talk
about because there's been this huge
question about whether Gavin Newsom is
the candidate in the wings and I'm going
to pass this over to our California
expert here in a second to talk about
this let's see what he said he said
let's see more technological change he
said they finally asked him about the
justice department court filings after a
lengthy pause during which the president
looked like he wasn't going to answer
any reporters we have the story from
SFGate San Francisco gate he decided to
weigh in I'm very proud of my son that's
all he said the White House spokesperson
who told various news outlets on Tuesday
the president forced lady first lady
love their son and support him as he
continues to rebuild his life we will
have no further comment look guys this
is a story where and look I know there's
been some happy talk out there across
the news networks across some of the
conservative media I've seen right-wing
sources where they say all right well
hold on just hold on this is just the
first shoe to drop Durham was out there
today he was testifying then we're gonna
have Weiss and we have other prosecutors
in Delaware and there's going to be
other investigations another trust guys
guys yeah look we now live and Jack
presovic was talking about this on his
award-winning podcast human events
earlier today
that we now live in not a one not a two
but a three-tiered system of justice a
three-tiered system of justice this is
the thesis that poso was lining out uh
and it's simple because we knew we lived
in a two-tier right we we all got that
in 2016. when James Comey we remember
this right we remember when James go
there that's that's what gets me is that
everybody's acting like this is normal
everyone's acting like oh yeah well the
president's son gets a you know gets a
plea deal and she's going to cop to some
of these you know tax charges and so he
lied to the ATF I mean look if any of us
lied to the ATF we'd get a deal like
this as well it's called a uh uh it's a
pre-trial diversion pre-trial diversion
is what it's called and it essentially
means that he's really sorry he admits
that he did of something very naughty
and he's definitely not going to do it
again I think that's the same thing that
would happen to any of us yeah if we
lied about I don't know our pistol
braces if we lied about our bump stocks
if we lied about shaving off uh or uh
well there's there's certain
modifications that can be made to a
semi-automatic AR-15 that we're
definitely not going to talk about here
but we could talk about in the members
show that if you're listening we're
definitely going to have a conversation
about that and more but if you lie to
the ATF we all know what's going to
happen you're in trouble you are going
to get messed up and
there is now a two-tier system A
two-tiered system that is turned into a
third tier system because one tier
that's the proletariat that's the proles
that's the regulars that's the hoi piloy
that's everyone else
then there's a tear there's a tier for
the aristocracy there's a tier for the
the leadership the political preferred
class just as poso is outlining again
his award-winning podcasts yeah really I
mean just just a smart and handsome how
does he do it yeah well no I mean he's
smart yeah beautiful family you know
beautiful family
beautiful family and he's smart I'll
give you that you know like cartoonists
yeah Family First Look I mean is that a
high bar if you want to set it there
yeah yeah give me that one more time
there's a three-tier system and then and
then there's a third tier and that third
tier is for people like Donald Trump but
not just Trump not just right Wingers
people like Julian Assange people who
are troublemakers to the regime people
for whom the the legal system the legal
standards get twisted into whatever
Arcane reading that lawyers and judges
will go along with to go after them a
paperwork dispute gets treated as if it
is uh handing over the nuclear codes to
Vladimir Putin we were being told Don
Junior was going to go to jail for the
rest of his life that's right that's
right down junior and so Donald Trump
call it too like early June wasn't just
like I guarantee you that they're going
to come after uh you know Hunter Biden
with like a small little slap to make it
seem like oh look the digestive system
is fair and actually I think the view
actually made a point of that they're
like oh look there no one's Above the
Law not even the president's son they
came after him and it's like come on
like you know imagine genuinely believe
imagine genuinely believing Justice is
served here that these are the penalties
that any other person in this country
would get if they were outside of that
narrow political class yeah he's the
Donald Trump is a Nostradamus every time
I'm just I'm just saying I try to think
about like when I first heard this story
like okay Hunter's getting getting off
easy I was like should he part of me I
was like yeah he should Joe should have
done the right thing and put his son in
jail for 20 years or 15 years for
whatever 10 years I don't know what it
is uh and then and now I'm starting to
question it I don't even know if this is
the way to go is to start arresting
everyone left and right for but I mean I
don't know what do you think but this is
these these are not minor things either
right so we see a lot of influence
pedaling we see a lot of political
leaders trying to profit off of their
position or the family members of
political leaders trying to profit off
of their positions and I think Hunter
Biden did that in a particularly
egregious way which is beyond the pal of
what we usually see in American politics
for as bad as that gets but on top of
that Hunter Biden didn't just commit
crimes that are outside the purview of
what the average American might do or
what they could be found guilty of or
being put on trial for so it's difficult
to to outline the fact that there's a
two-tier system when it comes to
influence peddling because your average
person isn't really in a position where
they're going to be able to do that so
it's difficult to compare the charge
they would get to the charge that
someone who's the member of a powerful
political family would get but when it
comes to the the gun charges or when it
comes to the dealings with money let's
say to to put it euphemistically and the
fact that he hadn't I believe reported
his income for fully to the tune of
hundreds of thousands of dollars uh Tim
can fact check me on that one there I
mean these are things that even in those
amounts your average American couldn't
be capable of but they could commit some
variety of those crimes and they would
get in way more trouble for it well it's
like Joe but President Joe Biden said uh
nobody F's with a with a Biden all right
or isn't that what he said well look
here's the thing though here's the thing
the very same people the very same
people that spent what did they spend
all last week doing when when that
prosecutor Jack Smith got up there at
the Department of Justice and he said
about Trump he said he they repeated one
refrain over and over the same refrain
you heard on MSNBC the same afraid you
heard on on every single network no one
is above the law no one is above the law
no one is above the law they were doing
that because they were front loading it
they were priming you psychologically to
prepare to respond exactly the way you
just said about Hunter Biden because
they want you thinking okay we did go
after Hunter Biden and it gives you a
false because it gives you an out to say
well that's not true Hunter Biden didn't
get off why look he was charged he
accepted a plea deal he had to do all of
these all of these different things he
had to pay the money back and they
looked into it and he was charged there
therefore therefore it's okay to go
after Trump but here's the thing Donald
Trump isn't going to be offered a plea
deal that being said Donald Trump's
he's not going to take a plea deal okay
there's nothing in Donald Trump's psyche
that would allow him to admit fault
admit any of this and he did an
interview with with Brett Barron there's
people coming back and forth on that
saying oh it was great I think it's a
roshock test like so Trump supporters
are saying uh this was a great interview
this was wonderfully knocked out of the
park and then uh Trump detracted her
saying oh this is terrible he's done
he's done for he's this is the end of
trump the walls are closing in his
lawyers are committing suicide as we
watch uh you know he's this is the end
the end of trump and then you've got
people in the middle who are like I
still don't understand he's why he's
being charged because they asked him
about the classified documents and he
said he Declassified them and they said
he was was president when he
Declassified them and then he also said
oh by the way there were uh you know
socks and shoes and commemorable shirts
and different things in these boxes
because remember we're showing the
picture of the boxes
and yet we're not actually showing what
was in the Box yeah in fact you can't
see what's in the boxes but that's great
persuasion right visual persuasion look
at all of these boxes
they're full of exactly they're they're
just up to the brim with classified
documents but yeah Declassified I think
that what this shows is once again the
Democrats are using are willing to wield
full power and come after anyone I mean
they literally have the political leader
of the Republican right you know you can
argue that it might be DeSantis oh it's
time for Trump to step down Trump is
still the face of the Republican party
like there is no Maga without you know
Donald Trump right now that's just a
reality I and I hear this not just you
know I'm not from a red state I'm not in
a conservative state but by any means
I'm in Los Angeles California regular
people like Street vendors that I talk
to they're just like no yeah Donald
Trump is the Republican he's that guy
and so what it kind of pisses me off a
little bit when I see that you know
they're coming after like Adam Schiff
like Republicans can't even do that
successfully coming after Adam Schiff
trying to censure him and I think that
you know last week we were just talking
about this uh they try to find them a
multi-million dollar dollars and and you
know Thomas Massey I think is a great
politician but he's like oh well we
don't want to open the floodgates we
don't want to have him pay a fine
because what what what would happen if
Democrats came after us and they did
that and I'm like buddy like those days
are way over man you know what I mean
like we got to stop thinking that way
and I think that that's why
conservatives continue to lose all the
time because they're just well we don't
want to cross that line because you know
well what if they came and did it to us
we just went through three years of
tyranny medical tiering like it's just
insane that we're still thinking this
way I cannot believe that there are
still conservatives online saying well
we don't want to cross that line because
well you know what if they come back and
do it to us whenever they can power dude
they literally indicted the leader of
the Republican party you think they care
about the the average Republican out in
the street trying to you know blue
collar worker they don't they arrested
your leader and nothing has happened
like what are we doing here look and and
there's there's just some numbers to
back this up from thehill.com has the
story 62 percent in a new poll say that
federal charges against Trump are
politically motivated that's from the
Quinnipiac University survey that was
released on Wednesday about these doj
documents Quinnipiac that is not exact
that's not you know that's not some
right-wing uh paid for Donald Trump
internal poll from his campaign or one
of these super back polls that gets
pushed around every time it's time to
you know get more donations out no no no
this is Quinnipiac this is a if anything
this is a poll that's that's going to
diminish Trump support and they're
saying 62 percent of all voters that's
not even weighted yes going into
Democrats Independents Etc look I think
that people
and specifically voters in this country
to your point I think they're they're
busy right but they're not stupid they
may not be looking into all the little
details of everything that Hunter did
they're not going to look into all the
little details of everything they're
alleging on Trump but they can see the
doubled sander in this case triple
standard they can see that there is a
different standard for those in power
who are favored and those who are in
power who are disfavored and and Sheamus
this is something that you and I were
talking about beforehand and
we're definitely going to get into this
more in the members only hour because
this is the type of situation
and Ian I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it as well this is the type of
situation that leads to instability this
is the type of situation that leads to
people checking out of the system
because they don't believe in the system
anymore this is the type of situation
that says to people look if they come to
arrest our guy if they're using the
power of the state if they're using the
power of force to go after our president
at the our leader our opposition leader
and if this is happening in any other
country we call it exactly what it is
yeah we called exactly our opposition
leader right if this happened you know
this is something that when people go
after Putin they say oh Putin arrested
his opposition leader exactly the main
thing imagine if Trump had right imagine
if he actually had put Hillary Clinton
in jail right exactly it would be about
how we are a fascist third world country
you you pointed out that about 60
percent of Americans see this as
ideologically motivated when it comes to
the charges against Donald Trump part of
what concerns me as it's almost
inevitably the case that some some
number of that 60 of people not only
believe it was politically motivated but
think that it was also a good thing so
some large number of people probably say
it wasn't politically motivated and
that's why I believe Justice is being
served here but there's likely a
contingency that really does believe
that this was politically motivated and
it's good that it was politically
motivated because they believe in
arresting their political opposition
because they know that they're on the
side of Truth virtue Etc all the
self-aggrandizing things that they would
say to promote their ideology when it
comes to this question of political
instability I remember what we heard
repeatedly through the 2020 riots in
order to justify the violence that was
happening in the streets was that
rioting is the language of the unheard
if that's true why are you trying so
hard to silence the right in this
country if you genuinely believe that
people become violent when they don't
have the proper political channels it is
an outlet to have their voices heard
what do you think is going to happen if
you arrest the leader of the Republican
Party a former president and the
front-runner for the upcoming election
this is the problem right this is the
problem I mean this could this could get
dangerous this is what leads people to
instability this is what we've seen
happen in country after country this is
what leads people to say
and we don't want this I don't want this
no my kids I don't want anyone who says
they do is a larper I don't want my
family I don't want people to live
through something like this but at the
same time we also can play things out
and this is something that Tim Prime has
been talking about here on the show for
years for absolute years saying that
we're seeing this type of instability go
back go if you had told somebody 10
years ago 10 years ago that we would see
the president United States House raided
that we would see the opposition
president arrested that if you and if
you if you take the leps uh the left is
out there saying there already was an
Insurrection okay they that's their
claim they're the ones who have already
said that the Insurrection had 1.0
already began and so you were pushing
people further and further out of the
system at the same time when you refuse
to look into and YouTube says we can
talk about this now if you refuse to
look into election irregularities if you
refuse to look into the way that ballots
are counted the way the ballots are done
because we threw
generations of traditions out the window
in the name of covet in 2020 then double
download it in 2022 in places like
Maricopa County where uh where Kerry
Lakes voters were turned away in droves
saying that we can't vote we can't count
the ballots are not printed right put
them in door three oh don't worry door
three is going to be fine these Maricopa
County machines etc etc don't worry
it'll all be counted I'll be taken care
of people turned away they went home
I'll I'll present when you don't when
you last point is when people don't
believe in the Integrity of the system
it leads them to seek alternate options
yep yeah but I I would also argue
because again I'm in Los Angeles we you
know one of the things that I do
differently than I would argue a lot of
people is that I'm directly involved
with the community and and I I know what
what their needs are I know what they're
asking for but the reality is is that
you know and I'll be honest I voted for
Donald Trump 2020 but his biggest fault
is to continue to push that narrative
and it's great you can believe in
irregularities Etc but guess what out in
Florida uh you know you had some of the
strictest election laws passed by Ron
DeSantis Democrats are still winning in
in Florida you have people that you know
are uh winning in mayoral seats out
there in Florida why because Republicans
I'll be very honest with you man
Republicans are sometimes losers I'd say
about over 90 percent of Republicans
conservatives Christians they have this
defeatist attitude this dumer attitude
about everything uh you know there's a
lot of people that flee California I'll
be honest with you I I've planted my
banner of Christ in Los Angeles I have
no plans on leaving ever because I I
refuse to seed a single inch to Godless
people to the Communists whatever it is
I I kind of hate and I am kind of like
kind of sick and tired of seeing
conservatives often post you know and
Jack uh or Tim 2.0 I apologize for this
but sometimes when we tell people like
it's time to flee the cities it's like
dude when when you're at War you need to
reinforce Warriors on the front lines
and you saw you saw it for yourself man
you came to Los Angeles uh you got to
see all the Catholics out there you saw
the Protestants out there fighting back
Armenian parents are starting to fight
back man like in no way shape or form
can I believe and I'm new to this party
I I was never political before I I
didn't even vote 2016. I'm new to the
conservative side I just believe that
due to my uh Christian upbringing I'm
just naturally conservative and you know
my whole family votes Republican now but
it's alarming to me to see the party of
1776ers that you're not going to take my
guns the you know we need to fight back
convincing people convincing Christians
this is the most alarming to me is you
need to abandon all these parts of
America and just Flee for safety and the
problem with that is it's not going to
be the ballot harvesting it's Wisconsin
just overturned its Supreme Court right
the the the Supreme Court at the state
level Arizona just went blue we're not
winning swing States why because we are
convincing conservatives and Christians
abandon our hope it's time to head to
high ground and people are going to one
of three places Tennessee uh uh Texas or
Florida there is no Christian there is
no conservative saying you know what
maybe our votes don't count here in
California maybe we should move to swing
state Michigan and help make it more red
that's not the message being promoted
and when you have a again no no fault to
Trump maybe a little bit of fault but if
all you're doing is going around telling
people the system is rigged there is no
hope look in my County our we had a
Republican state assembly woman and she
lost by 577 votes the reason she lost
was because over 30 000 Republicans in
my district didn't want to go vote
they're like what's the point if and and
the thing is when you have Christians
this is again if you're you know atheist
if you are you know liberal or more
libertarian I can maybe understand it
but if you're a Christian conservative
your message to Christians should never
ever ever be I mean dude his disciples
of Jesus Christ were sent to the most
extremist places on Earth and he said
you will be persecuted for it so to me
it's kind of alarming to see so many and
so it's it's not going to be the ballot
harvesting it's just there's going to be
no Republicans left and and to talk
about the institutions you know people
want to be upset at Elon Musk because he
hired you know this NBC person but what
conservative is out there telling people
hey guys don't flee the cities actually
become a judge become a lawyer so that
we actually have a fair fight at when it
comes to crimes oh but the radical D.A
okay but who's running against that D.A
where are our conservatives I mean
there's so many Reds say people yeah
people flee to Florida their people flee
to Texas and they're harboring all this
power and money but then those states
are also not becoming as red as people
want to say so now we're losing
Wisconsin we're losing swing States we
just lost Arizona I I wish I I could sit
here and tell you it's the ballot
harvesting it's not it's just that
Republicans have been convinced it's all
over this is it Donald Trump didn't win
bro let me tell you something man like
it's way more than Donald Trump it is
you at the local level there's so many
people that have fled California to Safe
States they've never ever held the
campaign never donated five dollars to a
local school board member and they're
just like oh I'm done and I'm like but
you never started you just you just
listened to your local conservative that
said it's time to leave California
there's a senator Scott Wilk who just
said that there was one bill that was
just passing well let's let's see I
think I think there's a couple things to
to deconstruct here firstly I don't
entirely disagree with you I think there
is some wisdom in saying it could be
good for conservatives to move to swing
States as opposed to states that are
already solidly red so they can help
those States
turn red or flip red in in local
elections and particularly presidential
elections that would be massively
helpful however I think a person
ultimately does have to make the
decision that's best for their own
family and if they're concerned about
moving to a state where their child is
going to be told by some groomer teacher
that they're actually a member of the
opposite sex and then put on puberty
blockers and then the child's gonna be
taken from the parent I would say that's
a realistic concern to think about and
so it makes sense for people to say I'm
going to go to a solidly red State
because while you're correct the
apostles did go to dangerous places at
some point it is time for lot and his
family to leave Sodom and Gomorrah
because it's going to be destroyed and
I'll also say if your plan is to go into
Nineveh and convert those people you'd
better be a Jonah right and even Jonah
had his flaws but you you you really
have to be in a solid place I think to
be capable of persuading people
especially in a very dark area a very
evil area of embracing truth so while on
the one hand I think some of what you're
saying is admirable about wanting to
stay in fight and not giving up your
territory I totally hear all of that
that said it's perfectly reasonable for
somebody with a family to say you know
what I see what's coming down the pike
here I see the the Christian persecution
that's ahead of us and I want to get my
family somewhere more safe where they
can flourish but look man I I have I
have three children a 16 14 and 7 years
old all of them are in public education
they see what's happening with the
public education Los Angeles but it is
my job as a father first and foremost
and also as a parent to teach them
they're exposed to lgbtism I tell them
hey we're we are Christians we don't
believe in everything that they believe
we believe marriage is between one man
and one woman and guess what my son just
got baptized last year despite laus D in
the public education everyone wants
something oh get them out of the schools
but why I mean you know it's a
relatively good school outside of some
of the stuff that they are teaching them
but my son 16 years old I was able to
raise him raise them right he's a
Christian young man he got baptized last
year my daughter 14 years old she just
accepted Jesus Christ as the Lord and
Savior got baptized just a couple weeks
ago the reality is that it is your job
as a parent to parent you know people
say like oh I don't co-parent with the
government dude if you pay taxes you're
already co-parenting because you're
funding a lot of stuff that are going to
affect your children are going to affect
everything that you do in life and the
reality is if I'm able to do it and and
I agree with you there are some people
that really have to go but I think it
should be a last measure you know there
was a a post by cat turd he posted you
know here's five rules to save your
family uh rule number one get the hell
out of your blue State second one is go
buy land in the middle of nowhere uh uh
in a red State the third one is grow
your own food Fourth is homeschool your
children five pat yourself in the back
because you just save your children bro
there's a lot of homeschool uh uh kids
that are not right you know like just
because you homeschool it's not a
promise of of be uh of being raised
right or you're not going to be raised
conflict there's a lot of people that
homeschool and unfortunately their
children go out to college or university
or whatever it is but my argument is not
against people that hey if it's right
for you but the reality is a lot of the
people that I speak with that leave
California it's because of one thing and
it's it's it's mostly economical and
they're like hey you know what uh my
house has become I can't buy a house out
here whatever it is
um uh you know and and so I need to move
to a different state to pay lower taxes
to to pay less in gas prices Etc but I I
just don't believe in that personally
man I I just don't I don't think I was
put on this Earth to pay low gas prices
I'll deal with the gas prices by working
harder making more money and I and I get
the children's stuff but it you know let
my testimony not be the standard or to
be exalted but to show to people people
dude even in deep blue Los Angeles on
the front lines of Communism where
antifa and black lives matter basically
run the city council dude here we are
baptizing kids because there is a need
for that and let my children you know my
son when he started school last year
he's in he's going to 11th grade now
he's like hey Dad just to let you know
there's two trans kids that are are
changing out in our locker room like
well what do you mean by that they're
like well it's two girls that pretend to
be boys and so they're allowed to be in
the locker room you know what I told
them I didn't tell them like oh you
better start standing up that I just
said you know what son that is their
lifestyle we don't agree with it I
taught you differently we read the Bible
you know that a man is a man and a woman
is a woman and then a couple months
later you know what he he was just like
well that's just the way it is because
look man you can Shield your children
that's fine but eventually they're going
to have to face the real world and to me
I've prepared my children to to
understand that there are different
Lifestyles but you don't have to pick up
your family like oh I'm out of here I
don't want them to see you know the gay
you know or anything like that it's
going gonna happen no matter whether
it's YouTube ads I don't know about that
you look at the tonight non-binary
fetish porn in schools but so Tim has a
good friend what's your point about yeah
to your point about about you know my my
recent my normal refrain about stick get
out of cities
um you know and and I specifically think
about that in terms of children right in
terms of people with children that when
I say get out of cities that is
different necessarily from or when poso
says it
um that is different from the overall
political power question so when I'm
saying that it is predominantly about
crime and predominantly about the fact
that we have wanton crime throughout
every single major metro area in the
United States homicides are still up
over pre-pandemic levels this is largely
because of depolicing that has come on
the heels of of the racial Reckoning uh
in the wake of George Floyd and you can
look at every stat you can look at it
from homicide rates to traffic
fatalities that go up in the immediate I
mean within days of George Floyd's death
to the point where you know you've got
the mayor of Minneapolis is out there
twerking this week twerking in the
street uh we could just see if we find
the clip at some point but this is what
Jacob fry is doing out there in the
meantime his city has seen homicides
explode to 1990s levels so when I say
get out of cities I mean get out of
cities so that your family can live so
that your family can actually uh not not
be killed by Strays or whatever it is
but at the same time when you're looking
at elections which is a separate topic
uh and then you're also talking about
potentially schools so there's there's
three different layers here so one's the
personal safety layer right you need to
get out of a high crime area that's
that's it's as simple as that you need
if you can you need to get out of a high
crime area uh certainly if it's
controlled by democrats if controlled by
Republicans in a tight crime I'd really
like to know where that is because I we
haven't actually been able to found any
so Gavin Newsom will play this game by
the way and Sean Hannity I guess wasn't
smart enough to respond to him in this
way and say well red states have some
you you know uh High homicide rates as
well they said well yeah but it's
certain cities within those red states
that are throwing the overall rate up so
in a state like Louisiana it's the City
of New Orleans in a place like uh
Missouri it's the city of St Louis and
et cetera and Ferguson area so this this
all goes around and so the issue then
becomes from to to respond to you on the
the ballot harvesting question Democrats
have played an incredible game of
beating debt of beating Republicans and
the right and independents and every
other uh candidate every other race
party out there because they've been
able to change the laws that we were
talking about earlier they've been able
to change the laws game the system to
the point where they've got massive
organizations of dark money whether it's
Soros whether it's Lori Powell jobs
whether it's Reid Hoffman that's Steve
Jobs Widow they're throwing millions and
millions of dollars Behind These
operations because they know they can't
win on the issues they know they've lost
on all these issues but what they'll do
is they'll go into swing States they're
going to places like Michigan places
like Wisconsin places like others and go
in and run these ballot operations early
vote harvesting operations ballot Chase
operations Arizona Georgia Georgia of
course passed a law changing this
fighting back so at least they have some
ability to fight back and a just massive
shout out to my boy Scott Pressler and
also the Turning Point Turning Point
action just signed a 5 million dollar
deal with Scott presser just for
Wisconsin just for Wisconsin investment
of five million dollars to say you know
what we're going to fight back hire
people put political boots on the ground
in terms of this because you need to be
able to do that and so turning point is
holding and there's a I'm told it's
almost sold out at this point
um a conference with Scott Pressler down
in West Palm it's going to be this July
1516 Scott Pressler Mike Lindell also
there my boy melindell uh Donald Trump
Tucker Carlson Steve Bannon myself
Charlie Kirk
um everybody is going to be at this
thing and Josh Hawley JD Vance Benny
Johnson said you know a million
neighbors I can't even think of that are
going to be there but it's specifically
on this question it's not just some you
know oh rah-rah look at us how you know
we we love America we're gonna hold you
know kiss the flag Etc no other
chromosome will also be there that it's
it's specifically on this question of
how we can use these targeted ballot
operations to win because I I don't see
it on the right I see the right actually
taking these strategic moves to get into
the Tactical level on the key states
that you need and Charlie Kirk has a and
Richard Barris has said this as well
that there are essentially just three
states you need you need three states
and you can flip the presidency you flip
the presence you get the culture back
and you're seeing fights like we did in
Los Angeles to actually not only win
back the school boards but also pushback
and I'd love to get into the next story
which is the story that that you were a
part of and uh well Jack was a part of
that and we have it from nbcnews.com and
and I'd love to hear your your
Recollections on the event your coverage
Catholics and other religious protesters
gather at Dodger Stadium on Pride night
the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence
whose members dress in drag as nuns were
honored for their work and this is of
course the NBC right version so we'll
tell the story we'll listen to NBC's
story and then we'll tell the story of
what we actually saw with stop
anti-catholic hate and God will not be
mocked signs protesters surrounded the
main entrance to Dodger Stadium on
Friday hours before the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence were where to
receive an award on LGBT Pride all right
I'm gonna have to stop right there
because the very first sentence of this
is not true it wasn't hours before the
sisters of Perpetual Indulgence uh were
to receive the award we swarmed the main
entrance while they were receiving the
award and we were out there with
rosaries we were out there with uh
thousands of people the LA Times
actually came out and admitted that it
was 2 000 people so if the LA Times
admitted it was 2 000 people it had to
have been at least four thousand five
thousand uh six or seven I couldn't even
lost count of how many helicopters news
Shoppers were up in the air uh do we had
drones flying all over the place and and
it was peaceful it was prayerful we had
a bishop uh reading a prayer of exorcism
Sheamus you'd appreciate Bishop
Strickland not not only not only gave a
prayer of exorcism but a prayer for
perimeter protection from demons wow and
this was the only time it's funny
because I thought about it was already
performing at the stadium I know right
so inside while all this is going on
there's there's the March that takes
place takes up space blocks the gate the
inside at that time is completely empty
during the ceremony you could go in and
Savannah Hernandez did actually go in to
get the footage showing in empty Stadium
while they received the award and of
course the fact Checkers are coming out
saying well hold on a second people
actually went to the game and they were
able to see the Dodgers play and they
play played a game against the Giant and
lost the entire series by the way to the
San Francisco Giants from Northern
California
um like the worst loss in 125 years wow
and that's awesome and then these are
like the you know the hated Rivals right
the Dodgers and the Giants and they go
on to lose this in in a massive fashion
but the ceremony itself was completely
drowned out by the protesters so
peaceful
and I you know what I didn't see though
was and look I've been or Posto's been
to hundreds of events with antifa uh got
into it interactions face to face say
what you will
I didn't see any of them there I didn't
see any of this I saw a couple of
counter protesters
across the street and you know it's
funny well because I was telling you a
couple of revcoms but they never crossed
the street and I kept wondering why
aren't they question when they come
across and then someone I was there with
goes well did they not cross the street
or did they not cross the perimeter and
it's like yo
Bishop Strickland so look look I mean
just from from my recollection my
perspective it was incredible it was
incredible to see I mean Sheamus of
course is being lazy didn't want to come
out yeah because that's exactly what I
didn't want to listen lazy didn't want
to support the faith didn't want to show
up when it mattered you know he's
willing to be here Tim you weren't there
to be Catholicism oh right I mean poso
was there and uh and then some of us you
know some of us showed up when it
mattered like our good friend here so
tell us what was it what was it like for
you on the ground what were your
Recollections
um was was it what the media says was it
an anti-lgbt hate Fest
um no so um I think it was a beautiful
full site because it was the first time
their Protestants and Catholics were not
at each other's neck about who's right
about what so it was kind of nice to
just be alongside God-fearing people
people who believe in the Gospel of
Jesus Christ just going around and
finally standing up to what I thought
you know was was a satanic agenda that
was happening at the Dodger Stadium with
these sisters of Perpetual Indulgence
who openly mock uh you know and
blaspheme our Christ but you know what's
so interesting to me is Christians will
will and this is why again sometimes
like 90 95 of Christians conservatives
sit at home all they do is type online
don't know what the heck they're talking
about never been involved in anything to
any capacity
um and they just like to just you know
oh this is stupid a protest what's the
point of a protest what's a what's the
point of a prayer walk what is that
going to do people that never show up to
the community and of course just useless
I'm sorry I'm kind of bashing on them
right now but um uh it was it was it was
really good to see you it was a great
site thousands of uh you know uh Jack
basoli book was there he's not here
tonight but but it was a great sight to
see him and I was just kind of wondering
there's a lot of like other influencers
that go hard in the paint for for Christ
and just weren't nowhere to be nowhere
to be but
um we were there man you know and there
was a like revolutionary Communists that
were there
um you know talking about there is no
Jesus there's no this but it was it was
really good to see just uh this this
public display of of Christians coming
out uniting uh saying the prayers
marching as men it's the most men I've
ever seen activated usually Conservative
Christian men are at home drinking their
Bud Light so it was actually nice to
kind of see them come out into the
street and actually uh act out the
things that they professed one of the
things that I was a little bit upset
about was that the Archdiocese of how
does that work I know you guys have like
a structure within the Catholic system
it's like the Archdiocese I don't know
if that's like a like a little small
government of of Catholic Branch inside
but so each I mean the the basic
breakdown is is you know a dice a parish
is a diocese so one church is usually a
parish that's one Community basically a
neighborhood then the Archdiocese
they're typically based around Metro
areas okay so you'd see the Los Angeles
archdiocese I was born and raised in the
Philadelphia archdiocese Tim Prime was
born and raised in the Chicago
archdiocese me too um your Chicago
Choice as well yeah yeah and then so and
then that would sort of uh raise up then
there's a Catholic conference for the
Bishops of the United States there's a
number of cardi B so there's a number of
cardinals there's what five Cardinals in
the U.S right now uh I believe outside
my head you'll be totally wrong and but
it's not a lot it's not a lot of
Cardinals and then all of the Cardinals
around the world eventually uh choose
the pope whenever there's it's time
comes time to choose new pope yeah and
so that's that's the base I mean there's
way more to it than that but that's the
very basis so basically the Archdiocese
of Los Angeles came out they were
supposed to be leading this I think that
thousands more people would have come
out had they actually endorsed it but
days before the prayer walk they
basically backtracked and said hey you
know what um where we're actually not
going to endorse any protests we're
actually wow we've decided that we're
just going to have open dialogue with
the Dodgers and any parties involved
meaning the sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence
um but you know I it's weird because I
have Christians telling me well yeah
that was a good call because what's the
point of a protest who cares like we are
meant to be persecuted as Christians the
thing I care about is that these same
Christians had it been that they were
mocking Jewish rabbis it was if it was
Jewish rabbis that they were making fun
of and the ADL put out a statement we
strongly condemn these sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence that dress up as
rabbis and are you know mocking the
Jewish faith this is not Christians
would have stumbled over each other as
the Marco Rubio's and and other you know
uh uh people that uh are always like
standing up for Israel and its allies
they would have been like oh we stand
with the Jewish people and this is not
this is we we which by the way there was
a rabbi actually at the event there was
uh Rabbi Michael Barclay from Los
Angeles was at the LA area right so they
spoke at the event right before Jack
russovic right yeah I remember that and
so to me it just it's mind-blowing to me
when Christians justify that it's okay
to persecute Christians in Christian
America country founded on Christianity
and that but if it was Islam it'd be
islamophobia and if a rabbi it's
anti-Semitism but it's perfectly fine
when it's done to Christians and so to
me I'm like okay well you can't have it
both ways either we can make fun of the
Jewish people and the Jewish religion
and we can make fun of Islamic Islam
people and Muslims or it's it can't be
it can't be that you know like you gotta
have it I'm all for it we're sure we're
going to be persecuted yeah we're going
to be blasting this and that but what I
don't understand is why you have
Christian legislators including just
recently Governor Ron DeSantis went out
to Israel and signed an anti-semitic
bill out there in Israel and promising
you know Israel like Hey we're going to
make sure that there's no anti-Semitism
in Florida they've extradited three
people in three different states I
believe two Florida under that new new
anti-Semitism bill but it's like but why
can't we do that for Christians this is
a Christian country we have Christian
majority legislators why isn't the
protection so my argument against
Christians and again I don't understand
why we do this but Jack posto was there
well you know we were there we showed up
we understand the importance of showing
up for our religion for our people
um and and just standing in solidarity
because to me it's just not right well
and and to to your question about the
legislation that there are obviously uh
concerns about uh what constitutes
protected speech under the First
Amendment as opposed to what what is
considered hate speech or hate crime
laws hate speech laws
um which you know we're not going to get
into right here but that's obviously a
major concern but also and Sheamus I
want to ask you about this as well
because this call by the Archdiocese
yeah for dialogue that's a communist
tactic that's a hegelian tactic this is
the exact same thing and I know the
thesis the antithesis exactly so classic
exactly so you have you have the thesis
you have the antithesis and then and
after dialogue it ends up breaking down
into the synthesis you have a new idea
now I'm not going to sit here and claim
I know what the motivations of the
Archdiocese were in making this decision
but what I can tell you is that I
personally believe it was a very bad
decision I think that this is something
they should have called for so that
people in the area would know that this
protest was something that the church
was sanctioning and there's a lot of
conversation in the Catholic church
today among Bishops and Priests who
consider themselves to be more moderate
about trying to unite with and have
dialogue with Protestants so it's
interesting that at this protest that so
many Protestants were attending it was
decided that the church couldn't and
even shouldn't endorse it of course I
think the reason is pretty clear if I
were to guess the motivations I would
say it was simply a case of them being
afraid and them not wanting to say
anything that would upset the alphabet
people the lgbtqiaap lobby or anyone
else who's pushing for sexual perversion
in this country because as you know
the the dominant prevailing State
religion that's been emerging is one
which celebrates sexual perversion and
unfortunately uh as is to be expected
just given human history the history of
the church in in the way human beings
behave there are people in the church
who would like to be accepted by those
who would persecute them because they
don't want to face the ostracism that
would come along with persecution and so
they're either willing to bend the knee
or even if they don't bend the knee
they're willing to tell other Christians
to stand down to tell the faithful to
stand down to tell Catholics to stand
down and not adequately combat the evil
as it must be but so then so then if
there's if there are these these at
least at least two thousand according to
the LA Times 2 000 which means to me
that there must have been at least
double that because the LA times has to
have been two thousand I saw it on Daily
Mail as well because Daily Mail
originally said that there would be that
there were hundreds of protesters right
hit refresh and then it's immediately
said top of and it stayed up all weekend
thousands of protesters so Sheamus what
is this split inside the church then
because is there a split between uh you
know the phrase at the laity the laity
of the church or members of the laity
into the hierarchy the magisterium at
least in the U.S
um not to go to Uber into the Catholic
weeds here but it just seems like
there's a split between the trads and
the moderates yeah well the the trads
the the modernists the moderates there's
a lot of different ways of looking at
this and to be honest I don't consider
this to be in any way shape or form
unprecedented if you look at church
history once the Roman persecution ends
a great deal of Catholic history ends up
being the story of good holy faithful
lay people being saddled with a corrupt
hierarchy that has some good people in
it but who do not follow the lord as
they should and do not lead their flocks
as they should and we also see this in
the the Holy Scripture is I believe as a
Catholic that at the Last Supper when
Christ established holy orders that
Judas was ordained so this is one of our
first examples of a priest and a bishop
and he betrayed Christ so we should
expect to see that there will be judases
in the church today and as we've seen
throughout church history it has been
full of them historically so when people
are unwilling to stand up for Christ and
when Bishops and clerics are unwilling
to which many of them are lay people
fortunately historically have risen to
the occasion even though it has not been
all of them many of them have and it's
it's what we should expect to see not
only among the hierarchy but among the
laity right because many seek to enter
and few do how many people truly take
their faith seriously how many people
are truly trying to get closer to Christ
and enter the Kingdom of Heaven surely
it's a minority and I believe that the
scriptures make that clear I'll also add
that it is not something disobedient or
offensive or even subversive for a
Catholic to say that there are many in
the hierarchy who are bad the venerable
Archbishop Fulton Sheen said that he
believed that the laity were going to
save the church and it's because again
we've seen it repeatedly with the the
hierarchy abdicating it is why it was
once said that the road to hell is paved
with the bones of priests and the skulls
of Bishops or the lampposts that light
the way amazing you know there's there's
actually a book that actually talks
about this too by Dr Taylor Marshall
it's not a plug or nothing like that but
uh he talks about the infiltration of
the church how it's been going on for
over a hundred years now and it's really
good because it basically talks and
there's actually a written testimony by
Dr Bella Dodd who in the 1930s 1920s she
was head of the Communist Party of New
York and she instilled 1100 communist
agents into the highest ranking
positions of the Catholic church because
she went on to say that Communists knew
that the only enemy that they feared it
wasn't the Jews and it wasn't uh Muslims
it was the Christian Church the Catholic
Church more specifically and they knew
that hey you know what we've done for
thousands of years we fought the
Catholics sword and shield and we
continue to fill and we continue to get
crusaded again so what you know what
we're going to do we're going to go
ahead and infiltrate and that's why I
think you know no disrespect to the
Catholic archdiocese is out of Los
Angeles what you are seeing now is the
reaping of the benefits and this is why
I say people need to plant your banner
and fight back because you know who
doesn't flee Communists don't flee when
Roe v Wade was overturned they didn't
say well it's guys it's time to pack up
from the red States it's time to head
over to California where it's a
sanctuary State these people mobilize
Man David Hogg the the unsuccessful
pillow uh guy right um and activist
totally destroyed by mypillow.com you
know what this guy did this guy
activated people in 45 States I showed
up to Los Angeles and I was to make
David hug cry yeah I I actually got to
talk so Roe v Wade overturned I'm in
safe blue California where a portion is
legal up to nine months uh on demand
basically and uh I talked to I talked to
some of the Communists there and I said
comrade you know or no not really I went
up to people and I said why are you
protesting here in Los Angeles where
here it's completely legal they said
because we stand in solidarity with our
brothers and sisters in other states
Christians have never done I can't think
of a single I can't think of a single
moment in time in my lifetime where
Christians in 45 states have mobilized
for anything why because they're on the
comments section saying it's time to
flee look and this guy is nuts this is
something where where it's it's I would
say it's a western church in general
it's it's not just the Catholics it's
it's you see it across Western churches
where they believe there's this idea of
spoiled decadent lazy Luke you know and
it's it's you are lukewarm and I spit
you out because you're another hot or
cold and it's this idea that you know if
you just sit down if you buckle down you
read your Bible every day you go to
church
have your personal connection but don't
do anything actually in the real world
right to you're being too generous I
don't I don't know many people in the
western church who are telling us to
read our Bible every week but it's a
mindset it is a mindset of of you see it
in the Catholic side you see it on the
other side just pray every day and Earth
will be fine but at the end of every
mass that I've ever gone to there is a
command and it says go forward yes go
forth Jesus simply go out and do things
Jesus didn't sit around in silence and
think about it he went out and talked
about it that's the purp that's how you
become entire that's that's part of
becoming touch with God take up space
this this church the centralization of
authority is what concerns me when it
comes to the Catholic any kind of church
any kind of tech company you know it's a
vulnerability the the the top of this
chain can make a decision and say we're
gonna say no you we're going to justify
that uh instead of instead of not
justified or it's like but but the
reality is your relationship with God is
bypasses any organization and when
people are moved by that I think you see
them go out and then they Inspire other
people to go out and move with it
I know very well about what you're
talking about about doubting the
hierarchy within the church sure yes no
so so I I mean I'd have a couple things
to say about that and and though I
disagree I I think there's a good
Instinct there and it's actually part of
why I I'm Catholic um so I I think that
there is a kind of vulnerability that
comes along with centralization and this
is a chestertonian argument but it's one
that I actually do find persuasive
cheekies it might sound and that is I
don't know how any organization as
corrupt as the Catholic Church could
last for two thousand years unless God
wanted it to there have been so many
horrible people in the church who have
done so many destructive things and yet
it's been around because as Christ
promised us the Gates of Hell will not
Prevail against his church I I firmly
believe that the the the
um what do you call them the the sins
and the virtues are really cool like
those are legit things to focus and live
by not not easy to but I mean if you can
live with those Seven Virtues pride is
one that I'm one wondering about it's
tough man yeah working Pride out right
yeah pride is an American virtue but
it's a Catholic sin so there's a there's
a there's a split Divergence already
when we start to have that conversation
about are you proud to be an American
because you're seeing against God but
then I'm thinking like well maybe they
mean Pride like not like hey I raised a
healthy baby I'm so happy about it
everyone and then you're like real Pride
as opposed to I can talk to God yes and
I'm gonna brag about it look how great I
am that I can talk to God like that's a
sinful way to live so I see that that
some but I don't know if that's beyond
Pride if that's arrogance if that's if
that's but I mean there are some things
that if you're proud of I think that is
sinful other things not so much well
you're actually getting to and I don't I
don't want to we have other smokers I
want to get to but what you're actually
getting at is one of the reasons that
the original what you might call
hierarchy but was actually the original
organization of the church came about
was because you would have in the
ancient world these various let me see
this today as well by the way you would
have these various people that say oh I
spoke to God and God told me this and
you guys might be reading uh this
writing of the Gospel you might be
reading this writing but God told me
this and so you have to add this part on
and now actually follow me and my
version of it which is totally different
from their version and so you would have
these competing versions of Christianity
some which were in line with the
original teachings some which went very
far astray you even at things like
various heresies the gnostics you had
the arena you had so many different
things going on at the time of people
who claim Marxism that they were in uh
direct communication with God because of
a personal relationship and so this is
what led to the original
of various ecumenical councils led to
the various Creeds et cetera Etc this is
just basic church history that of people
getting together because of this very
issue of saying well wait a minute you
know I just you you say three things at
church but then I went to this guy and
he said five other things who am I
supposed to believe right who's right
and this is why you get into the idea of
apostolic succession this is where it
comes from and not to be legal the
argument but that that is where it comes
from that's the actual history of the
church but well also you are the my rock
and Upon This Rock I should hold my
church and there's other points in
scripture aside from early church
history but I know it's a much longer
discussion it is but there's I guess I
mean to say there's a there's a
practical reason absolutely yeah but I
do speaking of practical reasons yeah
can I just speak to the point of Pride
really quickly not even just from a
religious standpoint but I think there's
something interesting where we talk
about Pride we talk about American Pride
and what we're referring to is
patriotism and I don't think we need to
use the word pride to describe it
because I agree with you pride pride is
a sinful it's bad God I think usually
when someone says they're proud to be an
American they're just saying that
they're patriotic now I know that one
thing that C.S Lewis said which I really
appreciate and I really find to be
brilliant is that Pride takes enjoyment
not in having things but in having more
than others so if someone's proud of
their wealth their wealth doesn't give
them Joy because they have wealth their
wealth wealth gives them Joy because
they have more of it than someone else
and so when you're proud as soon as
somebody has more than you or as much as
you they become your enemy hmm because
you hate them for having as much more
than well they've taken the thing that
matters that's the question of the of of
Pride that we're seeing now with pride
month in the U.S where is it is it we
are proud of our group or are we
flaunting our superiority exactly that's
the essential difference I think you can
be proud to be an American you might
believe that America is the greatest
country in the world and Superior to
other countries I certainly do
um but at the same time if you're saying
my group is better than your group
within this that's what creates problems
and that's what creates friction and
then the question is would you be less
happy with a country that does the
things right that America does if there
were other nations even better than it
that's where you sort of get into this
question of Pride like do I like this
because of how well-run things still in
certain areas many flaws with this
country but do you like this because of
how well things still are run in certain
areas or do you just like it because
other people are worse off other
countries aren't as good I'm proud that
the French yellow vest the dudes went
out and protest and maybe are right now
as far as I know but for years we're
willing into protest like that's like go
Humanity but then I still like Americans
Hong Kong talk about making me proud to
be an American human being those
Canadian dudes amen and women I mean all
of them but but that shows for you
farmers and I think that shows for you
like you're sort of your your pride and
your national identity doesn't come from
this diabolical place of I have to be
better than others it comes from a place
of I appreciate these principles because
you're happy seeing others embody those
principles and you're not going oh I'm
better than them so I should be the only
one doing it so that's a great perfect
segue into this next story that I want
to jump into here we have from
thepostmillennial.com Joe Rogan
challenges I love this vaccine
enthusiasm Enthusiast Peter who loves
them to debate RFK Jr I just get this
idea
another one doc boost me now boost me
down you have a boost to debate RFK Jr
on misinformation now we all know the
rules of the road I don't want to get
into any of the specifics because Luke
rudowski had played some of the argument
Ian you have the story what happened to
Luke when he played just a clip of RFK
from Joe Rogan don't actually play the
clippy no I won't I don't even know I
didn't see the specific uh I don't even
know if the video is still up um but I
just saw that Luke tweeted it out that
he reposted a clip of RFK talking with
Rogan I imagine from that show or from
the episode and that YouTube is like
your entire channel is now demonetized
so not just that video is the entire
channel that is really harsh that is
really harsh and it takes a lot for me
to say that about anything that happened
to Luke that's rough yeah yeah it's sad
to sympathize with Luke but I'm going to
because I stand up for all all Americans
and All Humans Free Speech must Prevail
well and I'll say this there are better
reasons there are better reasons to to
you know clamp down on Luke he's he's
awful this I I don't think what he did
here is uh is really working here so we
now see that we now see that Joe Rogan
uh he made the huge offer that's got
massive on Twitter uh Tim Prime was
offering money hundreds of thousands of
dollars I think it's up to 1.2 million
the last time I checked of money that
would be donated to charity by the way
if Peter Hotes MD PhD were willing to go
on to Joe Rogan and debate with him
about uh with RFK about the about
vaccines about the use of vaccines
vaccine mandates mRNA vaccines all of
these different things because they've
both been on Joe Rogan and now this
isn't like he has to go on and win the
debate this is just if you will are
willing to do this all of this money
will be donated to the charity of your
choice
and then of course he's saying I won't
do this uh there have been arguments
he's calling it threatening he's calling
it harassment
hundreds of thousands of dollars
that's a threat oh my goodness and so
what I want to ask is is this what do we
think well should the debate happen and
and here's the question that I want to
put out because I stand for free speech
I think do we all agree on that yeah we
all agree we all believe in debate
here's my question though
is a public debate the right way to do
medicine is this the right search for
truth is because that's of course that's
the response and so Devil's Advocate is
he saying well wait a minute that's not
how we do science uh you just were
talking about before about dialogue with
uh synthesis how can you have synthesis
if someone's just writing something's
wrong how do you respond yeah so what I
would say is that dialogue or
conversation with non-experts is not a
way to reach conclusion on or reach a
clear conclusion on any medical question
but that's not what's being discussed
here what what is being asked is whether
he can justify telling all of the
American people that they have to and in
many instances should be required to
either by law or mandate from their
employer to get this particular medical
treatment okay so there's a difference
there's a difference between saying the
medical process should be determined
based on a single public conversation
between a doctor and somebody who isn't
a doctor and saying well if the medical
science is as clear as they're claiming
and all of our concerns about people who
were scientists and who were doctors
being pushed out of the establishment
and silenced for their views can be
nullified and aren't actual concerns
then should this man who advocates for
the use of this particular medical
treatment be able to explain to the
American people with an adversary in the
room that this treatment is worthwhile I
would argue yes and I would argue that
while not everyone is skilled at
debating and therefore not going to be
equally capable of promoting a message
even if it's truthful
if he's not talented in this area or
rhetorically gifted enough or quick
enough on his feet to engage in that
kind of a conversation what he should do
is find somebody who is capable of
defending the position and then that
person should go on Joe Rogan and make
RFK look like a fool and then have well
over a million dollars donated to
charity of this man's choice and also
convince a large vaccine skeptical
segment of the population that they
should get the job that's what should
happen so you're arguing for a uh that
that Peter Peter Hotes can choose a
champion if I think it's a trial by
combat exactly no exactly if he's not
gifted enough to debate look that's
totally fair not everyone has to debate
not everyone's equally good at it it's a
different skill set at the same time if
someone offered me over a million
dollars to a charity of my choice to
have a conversation about something I'm
an expert on with someone who I claim is
a crackpot conspiracy theorist I cannot
imagine a rationalization for turning
that down I really can't and I'll say
this there are conversations that I
think are genuinely damaging so if
someone is promoting a new idea that the
culture is already completely against
and you could be giving legitimacy to
that idea by debating them so for
example if someone were saying that we
should have a public dialogue about the
acceptance of pedophilia I would be
unwilling to engage in that kind of
conversation because the public is
already against that and having a
conversation about it could give
legitimacy to that idea but this is
totally different but this is totally
different because the Public's against
it or do you just be against it well
because we're I think I also think we're
hitting moral Bedrock there where it's
just fundamentally obvious why this
thing is disgusting and you shouldn't
give voice to any opposition who would
say that something like that is morally
acceptable but this is different these
vaccines in this particular kind of
vaccine is something that has been
pushed under the American people which
the American people have not
wholeheartedly accepted at this point so
the burden of proof is actually on the
person introducing the new idea to have
conversation about it and they've been
unwilling and one last thing I'll say
about this is
all of the arguments that are being made
about the concerns that the medical
establishment has about making
conspiracy theories seem legitimate by
having conversations and debates
defending their Viewpoint are arguments
that they would have made about
defending the wet Market hypothesis
three years ago and we know how that
turned out so these people don't have
the scientific or moral Authority that
they have claimed that they have this
isn't a situation where we should all
sit down and shut up because they've
been right about everything they've been
proven wrong and with a track record
like there it is completely and
abundantly reasonable for the American
people to ask for a little bit of
transparency and have one of these
people have a public conversation about
what they're promoting to the American
people with one adversary in the room to
be able to give them some pushback
that's what I think I was just thinking
about the companies that make vaccines
and other medicines and how when you're
a corporation you have a duty to your
your stockholders to make money so that
there's already a thing like don't make
us sell less because we'll lose money so
we have to and like why is there a
profit motive in the medical industry
that is incredibly wrong so you want
socialism I'm kidding I want healthy
people I want to talk about diet I want
to talk about what Rogan was talking to
Peter Hotes about when he had him on a
show in the beginning which is what do
you eat and Peter's like I eat junk food
and Joe's like are you kidding me
there's so much evidence that eating
healthy gives your body resilience
against covet as much as men as much as
other things that you can get and
vitamin D do you take supplements and
Peter's like I don't really take
supplements he's like this is crazy that
you're you're a doctor but you don't eat
healthy and you don't take supplements
so I want to hear that conversation I
think Peter's probably very nervous to
get humiliated in public about his diet
um and also I think he's he's on on his
own against RFK Jr and Joe because
they're both as far as I know I'm very
much like eat healthy that's the
beginning and so I think it would be
reasonable if Peter brought another
doctor in with him yes and there was a
four-person debate even if Joe wants to
be a moderator I think he's biased about
this for very evil whatever
um and I know that Peter loves Joe but a
guy went to Peter's house hotels and
like got his camera up and was like why
aren't you doing I need to watch the
video yet but that's where Peter's
saying he's being harassed
um don't go to his house don't go to
people's houses this started on Twitter
keep it on Twitter which people were
kind of writing off at first they're
like oh yeah this never happened because
he like took to the tweet and he's like
um oh by the way I was just harassed at
my house and I think like a couple
conservatives like hopped on like oh
yeah just like juicy smolier you know
like or does he smell like like he was
attacked and then there was like video
evidence that it actually did happen and
then what yeah even before we jump on
these stories guys wait wait before you
call somebody a faker like yeah yeah
exactly one thing I love about the right
is that the go the goal polls always
shift for us and by the way like I know
I'm kind of like crapping a lot on
conservice today just because uh you
know somebody said like oh that Hispanic
guy is probably a rhino which is
actually accurate I'm a republican in
Gnome only because there is no political
movement right now that actually truly
represents and harnesses my outward
angward anger toward the government
um you know what I'm saying and so yeah
I am a republican name only but
Republicans get a lot wrong Michael
Knowles that at a conservative event he
said the Republican party is a party of
no Democrats present solutions they
might be they might be wrong they might
be uh stupid they might be outlandish
but at least they have Solutions and
Republicans are just a party of no you
know the Democrats are like oh we want
this health care and they're probably
like nope okay but what Solutions do you
have then and then the problem is that
there just really isn't a lot of those
Republican party but as far as the
debate goes
um I I think it absolutely should happen
I'm kind of like with you you know even
what you were just arguing against I'm
actually for it like dude let these
people make you know uh uh an example of
themselves like there was like that Ted
Talk that we're talking about like it's
time to talk about Minor attractive
persons bro identify every single person
that attends that Ted Talk and look into
their into their computers you know what
I mean like to me it's like bro why why
censor any of this this is why you know
like I I love turning point and I love a
lot of the conservative right but it's
like we self-censor people that we
consider too radical you know and it's
like I I I understand a lot of it has to
do with like donors and like Public
Image and we don't want to be associated
with some people but it's like dude if
if you're right then just go ahead and
like make the argument for it you know
like again and this is why it kind of
like uh irks me when it's like we claim
to be like oh we're all about free
speech like well what about this guy
like a little like that's a little bit
too much for us like we can't talk about
that because you know censorship donors
whatever it is sponsors you know and to
me it's like dude just talk about it and
just debate it and like if the person is
wrong then the person is wrong right you
know yeah
I mean the thing's gonna reveal the
truth honestly is just putting it into
open discussion I I I yeah I don't
entirely uh agree I think that showing
certain uh Lifestyles or bad behavior
can actually normalize it though I think
we're probably gonna have to agree to
disagree on that point if we're having a
broader conversation about whether this
debate should happen my main point here
is that even with the framework that you
can argue like an expert shouldn't be
having a conversation with a non-expert
about this or there are some ideas so
heinous that it would be wrong to
discuss them or debate them publicly
this certainly doesn't fall into that
category and I'll also add this we'll
just hold on um I will also say here
and that what is being what is being
posited here is a a non-medical expert
having a debate on a podcast with a
doctor now interestingly enough I
actually think that would debatably make
it more of a layup for the other side
right what they should be saying is it
wouldn't be right for me to debate a
non-medical expert therefore get me a
doctor get a doctor on your show who
disagrees with me so he and I can have
the conversation or get a panel of
doctors let me bring other doctors who
are specialists in the different field
uh that that are the different fields
that would contribute to this
conversation and then you get doctors uh
who are on the other side of the
question but it's not enough Dr Malone
maybe yes but the thing is like like to
your argument about like you know
whether it's the minor attractive
persons whatever well they're pedophiles
you mean a debate about with someone who
believes that well okay for example what
what has turned more people to the right
is the fact that lgbtism is running
rampant it's now at the corporate level
that has turned more people to the right
and it's turned more people to
conservatism it's turning people back
into the churches our churches are being
filled my pastor when he baptized my
daughter was saying that those are the
most teenagers that they baptized at one
single point and it's because people are
seeking Christ because the left has
completely gone berserk I mean look you
know Charlie Kirk great guy for a couple
years he was parading around you know
Rob Smith I respect that he's a veteran
I'm a veteran myself but people were
arguably asking them if we're fighting
the culture war and we're against
lgbtism because we're conservatives or
we're Christians then why are you around
going going around with uh uh Rob Smith
like what does that do to help fight who
is Rob Smith I'm not familiar with the
story he is uh uh like from Florida I
think he is a U.S veteran and he's
openly homosexual I think he has like a
partner he doesn't push the LGBT agenda
like he is he isn't you're you're you're
you're lying right now because you're
saying that he's going with Charlie Kirk
to promote the LGBT again no no that's
not what I've never seen Robin no I
never Charlie Kirk ever do that I've
never said that uh Charlie Kirk was
going around with Rob Smith
you're deliberately conflated both of
that no what I am saying is what I'm
saying is if we have the open debates
people can show up and make the counter
argument and be like hey this is wrong
we don't believe in this and guess what
Rob Smith is no longer did you just say
that Turning Point shouldn't deny people
the right to come speak at events and
now you're saying that Charlie Kirk
shouldn't be on stage no what I'm saying
is you literally just said that no
that's not what I said professors to be
a Christian man and he is a conservative
what what business does he have with an
openly homosexual man going around
campuses why can't he find another
Christian conservative to go around and
push the same point look I'll be very
honest with you I don't follow Rob Smith
why because I Journey like what what has
he said that has to be really impacted
my life nothing so why would I partner
with someone so why are you bother
buying so much no it's not that I'm
bother I was getting to the argument
about having open debate people went out
to to to
um Charlie Kirk and said hey if we're
fighting the culture war and we're
pushing back against this then why are
you out here with Rob Smith who is
openly for it and goes to his social
medias I mean it was kind of like the
whole Dave Rubin thing right we're
pushing about against transgenderism and
all stuff but like Blair white right
transgender person but the conservatives
will hell her like Caitlyn Jenner oh
because she's on our side but it's like
well no not really we're fighting
against this in general not just because
oh well they just happen to be trans and
left there so that's why we're against
it well then okay but as a Christian are
you against it completely or are we just
like well now we have base trans people
on our side and this is not I respect
Blair white and whatever you know that
guy's uh advocating for I respect people
like Ross Smith they all have their own
audience or whatever it is and with what
I'm saying is it took Catholic people to
come up to Charlie Kirk and say look if
we're supposed to be a Christian
conservative group and we're trying to
fight the Cold War especially with the
rise in lgbts lgbtism at the corporate
level then why are we doing the same
thing I think socially socially we're
just moving leftward both on the
conservative side and on the liberal
side it's because
um most of the religious movement that's
pushing back against the political
movement of I guess you see lgbtqia plus
political movement not the people
themselves is it never had any animosity
towards the sexuality itself there are
like very uh traditional religious sects
that do but the the broader Christian
Movement is more concerned with the
indoctrination of children whether
they're gay straight trans uh Christians
whatever and I think it it's okay it's
okay for religions to ebb and flow and
change over time so what the word of God
is forever though man you know like I I
agree that there's a lot of Christians
that say well you know it's about the
kids really this is about the kids I
mean I was called a religious bigot
because I said this all started with
same-sex marriage and the moment
contraceptives but I agree that well no
yeah sooner yeah absolutely but like the
thing is if again if you're a Christian
like it should always be at the very
beginning we should have been fighting
it and again look Roe v Wade got
overturned 45 States went out and said
hey we need Roe v Wade back when
same-sex marriage happened there was not
a single state that went out there as
Christians or as a church and said we
need to unite all 45 States and fight
against same-sex marriage you can call
me a bible thumper you can call me you
can call me you can call me a
Mediterranean thinking or or medieval
thinking sorry not Mediterranean
thinking about food right now yeah about
the Armenian parents but look at the
core when people like and and I feel
like we tiptoe a lot around this like
Christian conservatives were like well
maybe if we just focus on the kid part
maybe we can just leave it all out it's
like no dude Caitlyn Jenner bad Blair
white blood Rob uh bad Rob Smith bad
again I can respect him as people and
and you guys case in point my my son in
a locker room with the true trans kids
what the first thing I told them you
don't go ill you don't say I hate you
and you don't they're they're human
beings at the end of the day because
that's where Christians are taught right
Christians are taught to hate we're
taught like hey dude you don't you
respect and you love them and you pray
for them that's what you do
but you know that was my that was my
argument about that because if if you
allow for the open debate and the open
to to have people there then people will
push back eventually like for example
pedophiles if they start having a
national pedophile convention or
whatever it might be you should shut
that down immediately
but here's the thing why not do the same
thing for in Texas they're openly
that's you can be thrown out a lot
Sheamus I'd love to hear your response
to really this question I guess of
association should the conservative
movement associate which is really what
what your what your point is there the
conservative movement the populist
movement whatever you want to call this
associate with individuals like that
because uh there may be certain
lifestyle choices that Christians and
conservatives disagree with does
associating with these people uh degrade
the the Christian message and are there
times obviously in any Coalition there's
going to be friction are there times
when there's friction between the
Christian message and the conservative
message the conservative movement that's
a great question and there's a whole lot
to get into with the answer I'm going to
give there I want to say firstly
when you're examining whether it makes
sense to have somebody as an advocate
for your movement one question that you
need to ask is what is this person
publicly promoting in other forums also
how socially accepted is the thing that
they're promoting and is our working
with them going to Aid them in their
activism for pushing for things which we
know are bad and then there's also the
question of
what are we working towards with with
this person is there an expectation
being created that I am now on the side
of the perverse things they're promoted
or or promoting or am interested in
working with them on those things so
when it comes to a lot of people on the
right who are saying you know I'm openly
homosexual or I'm transgender and I have
no plans of stopping being either of
those things but I'm on the right and I
agree with conservatives on X Y and Z I
think that if you have to work with
someone to accomplish a certain goal and
they're not promoting the bad things
that they're doing that's one question
but then you have to ask yourself
another question which is am I only
trying to find someone from a
marginalized identity group to say these
things for me because I am too cowardly
to Simply say as a straight male who
does not struggle with a any kind of
sexual perversion that would push him
away from being interested in women that
perversion is perversion that evil is
evil that you can't harm children that
Democrats are trying to destroy this
country and many Republicans are
collaborating with them and that's a
that's a massive question that I think a
lot of conservatives need to start to
confront themselves with when
you have these YouTubers who promote a
perverse lifestyle to Their audience
members but they also say conservative
things are you promoting that person's
work because you genuinely think the
angle they have on this is so unique and
valuable to our movement that it
nullifies any concerns we might have
about what they're promoting to a young
audience or are you just too scared to
State your opinions without feeling that
you need to use a gender or sexual or
even any other uh person who'd be
considered marginalized or a gender or
sexual minority to make your case for
you because you're too scared yeah right
so when you're talking about is tokenism
right yeah and there is a difference I
agree with you that there would be a
difference if people were holding up
someone like Scott Pressler as an
example of tokenism I've never heard
anyone refer to Scott Pressler as the
LGBT activist Scott preswell because
he's not he's a republican activist he's
someone who's out there in the trenches
state after State campaign after camp
pain every single day for the last I
think eight years since I've known him
campaigning for Republican candidates
he's never one I've never once heard him
say a thing about his personal sexuality
or combined the two into politics or by
the way tried to use that as some sort
of you know Shield against criticism
exactly he just doesn't do it that being
said the man is an absolutely effective
operator and a passionate hashtag the
persistence uh Fighter for the movement
on that cause and so to to write him off
and say no you you know you can't
associate with us I don't think that's
the right move uh same with Rob Smith
same with the number of people the
question is what are they promoting
right what are they promoting outside of
the thing that you agree on I guess
that's a huge part of my but Ian you
were gonna yeah yeah sorry oh I was
thinking about Blair white who we've had
on the show uh multiple times and we
reflected after the first episode like
wow we didn't even bring up trans at all
we're just hanging out Blair man that's
the way it's supposed to be yeah exactly
and that and I agree with you I've
worked with Scott presser we just did a
cleanup about a month ago but because he
stays focused on the political and I'm
not saying that you can't have people uh
you know come on and for example I think
I think of anything the way I do a
church would you ever appoint anyone
that is LGBT as part of head of the
church what do you mean by head of the
church like at any position
yeah so so in the Catholic Church you're
actually not they're not supposed to
ordain you a priest if you're homosexual
they're actually not allowed to it
happens
but it's not supposed to yeah it's not
supposed to so to me I take that
standard it's a broken rule I apply it
to everything in life if you wouldn't
apply it to church why are we doing it
to Christian conservative organizations
now I'm not saying they cannot work
right we just had the whole debate with
the um with the chosen where they had an
LGBT flag on on set and now people are
canceling the chosenness it's not and I
think Candace Owens I think poorly uh
you know again massive respect for
everything she does I'm not I'm not here
you know I'm not like on this Rampage or
crusade to go after anyone I respect all
the these people because they're
pioneers and they've built something way
more than I could probably achieve I
don't know what God has planned for me
yet you know I'm I'm pretty young I'd
like to say but I don't know what he has
planned for me yet but what I always say
is that she kind of downplayed it as
like look we we have to hire these
people the the first thing that I
thought about was uh project Veritas
project Veritas before the whole James
O'Keefe Fallout they had a liberal uh
principle or like some kind of
superintendent that said oh there's ways
for us to find out how to get rid of CR
of conservatives doing the hiring
process and once again we prove that
Liberals are going uh are willing to go
above and beyond to make sure that they
hire the right people conservatives were
willing to use tokens where willingness
like well you know what I would never
say this but if we just hire this person
they can say it for us and then we can
just say like oh well you know what um
we can't really discriminate against
these people it is it is a corporation
you run it you you you claim to be
Christian conservative like you should
be the one deciding these things now
again like you said if we want you know
Scott presser I think he does really
great things it's why I've worked with
them but again never once ever he
doesn't start off his his speeches with
like hey guys um you know I'm totally
this or totally that here's my sexuality
he's never done it you've never exactly
but I mean
gaze against rumors what I mean has come
out and there's there's a whole movement
about you know separating the tea from
there's a lot there there's a it's a
complex look I'm gonna throw the bottom
of mine on this and I want to get to
another story before we want to go to
super chats obviously we're gonna have a
lively very Lively 10 p.m uh
it's gonna get a lot hot and twisted I
promise you uh because we're going to be
talking about all this and then we're
going to add guns
um that not like literally to the room
where we mean like in the conversation
yes yes in the conversation conversation
look uh uh at the end of the day look
we're up against regime
we're up against the globalist American
Empire we're up against billionaires
we're up against people who have massive
resources in terms of money massive
resources in terms of influence and we
have individuals doing this by
themselves people doing this
independently it would be so much easier
to just go along with whatever The
Narrative of the day is just go along go
along with funding Ukraine go along with
vaccines go along with LGBT like the
entire agenda go along with all of these
things and so when you are in
a Time limited situation and you are
seeking allies and you have the ability
to find someone who says you know what I
will fight with you I will come with you
and I'll fight with you we may not agree
on 100 of the things we may not agree
with 100 of the issues but I agree with
you now and I'm I will be with you in
this fight and that I will look to my
left and look to my right and who's with
me in the Foxhole and I will see who's
there and if that person is with me then
I'm gonna fight with that person because
I don't have the luxury of being able to
litmus test on this but I want to talk
about another case that's going on right
now it's a completely separate thing
yeah but a separate a separate gear look
we've all been talking about it it's
massive on the Internet it's massive
everywhere this thing about the Titanic
five these guys talking about a race for
time they're down there they're possibly
we don't know if they're still alive we
have no idea if they're alive right now
everyone that I know is talking about
this situation right now but you know
what's interesting and and shame as you
and I were talking before uh we got on
air about this there were people who are
rooting for them to die there are people
who are rooting for the ocean in this
situation and look I'm gonna be honest
I'll say this with you know I don't wear
in the beanie right now but with my my
formula you have a friend named Jack I
have a friend named his name poso who's
a former Navy officer uh these guys are
in Miracle territory they're in they're
in Hail Mary territory at this point
it's it is it is not likely right now
that they will be saved uh due to a
number of factors the severe and extreme
depth that the Titanic is at the fact
that this thing has as far as we know
has not surfaced uh they have an
emergency procedure where it can
resurface very quickly it doesn't appear
to have done that uh it's the same some
kind of damage
um there's been questions about the
whole uh integrity and if the hull is
breached I mean it's they've been done
the whole time yeah exactly as far as we
know there's no way you any human can
survive at that depth and certainly not
at that pressure you'd be you'd be
killed instantly basically if the whole
there was a whole breach
um that being said even if there wasn't
to be able to find this thing get
submersibles down there it's you you
just don't have enough time you don't
have enough air but what is going on
where there are people who say well
these guys are rich you know what they
get what they deserve and I think we
talked about it before and serge you
have the point as well we're always told
we're always told that oh we're we don't
hate the rich we just love the poor so
much they're exploiting the poor we just
love the poor really because I you can
go and look up I think it's called the
Titan you can look up the Titan type it
in Twitter right now and you will see
people arguing and cheering celebrating
the fact that they want these people to
die now and getting thousands of likes
and it's everywhere and I don't it's not
friends you know I don't necessarily
think that these guys are you know
Heroes I don't know if they're that
they're expl they're not Lewis and Clark
okay they're not Magellan yeah um yeah
there's people that have that have
pioneered these areas before they are
they taking a risk yes it is a foolhardy
risk I would say probably
um but that being said they're human
being yeah and they have families and
and to say that because this person is
wealthy I hate them and I'm going to
celebrate their death as an absolutely
sick thing to say it shows you exactly
how hateful they are I'm gonna quote
somebody I I saw a tweet from an account
called good tweetman and what he said
was
all of the people who are saying they
hope these people died and rooting for
them having a horrible death of the same
people who say
um I just want everyone to have health
care that's my form of extremism and
it's true now this just goes to show you
that the vast majority of people who
call themselves socialists or leftists
are in truth envious
they want to tear people down who have
more than them they want to see people
who have more than them suffer and even
die there's there's a very intense
Darkness here even though they claim
that they don't hate these people now
conservatives for example will be
accused of hating gay people basically
all the time if I heard a group of gay
people died in a submersible or in some
other horrible way I wouldn't be going
oh this is wonderful I don't I don't
cheer for the deaths of people whose
choices I disagree with and who I don't
like like my desire for people if I
think they're doing something wrong is
for them to repent turn to God have a
good life and get to heaven
die it's a go and sin no more and repent
not to die a horrible death so anyone
who who makes a claim like this anyone
who says that it's good that these
people died they've lost the moral High
ground but to be fair most of them lost
the moral High Ground long ago and their
world view is about hatred anger and
I'll leave you with this
most of the time when people are calling
for equality with their actual what
they're actually calling for is a
celebration of themselves in their own
aggrandizement because it's very rare
that somebody's calling for equality is
actually doing the work to help people
who are beneath them in terms of wealth
or social status they're almost always
looking to the people who are higher
than them and saying it is criminal that
I'm not on their level that they occupy
a higher position than me everything
that we were saying about Pride earlier
these are prideful people who are saying
any system that doesn't Place me at the
top is one which is fundamentally
corrupt and so I will celebrate when
people who are above me die which is
also which is also Envy Ian I want to
get your take because we got to get you
in the conversation here a little bit
more look I know you've been you've been
you've been crunching the numbers you're
looking at the submersible you've got
the Science Background what would be the
Ian Crossland way to try to get this sub
up oh man deep sea lasers
um like laseroscopy some some way to map
the the vibrations of it is so small and
the ocean is so huge and currents take
you so fast we were watching these jet
stream currents that things can get
caught up in they lost contact with the
mothership these things aren't
submarines they're submersibles they
can't go under alone so they lost
contact at 45 minutes 45 minutes it was
going to take them two hours to get down
and at 45 minutes I thought it was an
hour and a half so as you said is it
only two hours to get down I thought it
was like eight I didn't realize okay
maybe two and a half I think I saw two
and a half so really okay it was only it
was before they were even reached the
bottom that they that they disappeared
off off contact so that was like I don't
know Sunday Saturday yes and then I
think I think the hour and a half was
the final uh distress call an hour and a
half was a final distress call
purportedly they've got another 12 hours
of oxygen on board
um but that's assuming that there hasn't
been a great breach a hall breach I
don't know if they're hooked on the
Titanic somewhere if they're caught in
algae if they're on a net if they got
washed away and they're stuck under a
rock somewhere seven miles away they
they could actually be you know they
could actually be inside the Titanic
because there was a a story that someone
else this is not the first uh Voyage of
this sub and there there was a guy who
said that when they went down the last
time they actually essentially landed on
the deck of the Titanic look this
thing's been down there for a hundred
years if you're trying to land on the
attack of something Crush under that
pressure wasn't designed to operate at
that pressure as the surface level the
surface ship
um there's a there's a it's kind of
black humor but saying it now but uh
there's a there's a line in the in the
Navy that every ship can be a submarine
once it's kind of like how the
ukrainians found out that any any
vehicle can be a Minesweeper once
um the current counter-offensive
um yeah so there's that
um but they could have they could have
been attempting another one of these
Landings to say hey we're on the deck of
the Titanic and then believe it or not
we could actually be seeing an increase
in the death toll of the Titanic itself
well but then the question is if that's
a realistic possibility I mean why
haven't they been searching there or why
haven't they looked there I mean I
imagine it's difficult to get a
submersive
or that being said it could just be
because uh just because of the severe
depth uh again that's okay Navy hat back
on uh you can't you can't just get one
of these submersibles there on station
immediately it's not like you know it's
not a Marvel movie it's not the Avengers
the plane doesn't just like fly in from
you know the across the skies and then
everyone just flies down to the bottom
of the scene you have to get it you have
to spin it up you have to get it powered
you have to get it set you have to dial
in the parameters for where you're going
you have to get it on station
um you can't just fly something out and
drop it in typically you need a ship
tender for one of these things uh so you
need another ship that needs to be
prepared then that ship has to go out at
ship speed so you're talking about 10
hours 12 hours just to get on station
once you've got the the remote operated
vessel that's there remember our
favorite vehicle that's on station so I
mean you're you're fighting against the
clock the entire time the ocean is
massive uh this is way way down and it's
possible well that even if they have
something down there they have no clue
exactly what was going on and well the
controller disconnected right yeah the
thing was done it was controlled by a
Logitech controller that's insane look
at the video game controller video game
controller thirty dollars Logitech stock
took a hit I was reading okay as soon as
soon as I um I heard about this story my
conspiracy hat came back on and I was
like dude the Titanic is still taking
down billionaires because I'm sure you
guys have probably heard of that like
yeah about people on the Titanic uh
initially or like Bankers that didn't
want to do the Federal Reserve John
Astor was one of them I think right yeah
and then that's where you know Jekyll
Island and the bankers there and then
that's when they started the Federal
Reserve oh here we go
by the way by the way I just saw on on
Daily Mail real quick right real quick
on Daily Mail that I saw one of the and
one of the members of the current crew
the Titanic five that's on there right
now are actually descendants of people
who died on the original
well they wanted to see how you know
their their ancestor died that's a sad
thing they're going to explore the sight
of where a family member died now
they've very well may die and and you
know people uh on the left think that's
wonderful so
I will I'll ask you this at the depth
that they were lost about 45 minutes in
is is one contact was lost okay so my
question for you is approximately what
depth would they be at at that point do
you have a good answer for that or is
that sort of outside of your you'd be at
least a couple hundred feet down okay so
then my question is if not a couple
thousand yeah yeah what could happen at
that depth I mean would this just have
been a problem with the submersible
itself or are there currents that could
come sweep you away very quickly all of
the above okay okay it's honestly all of
the above because in this thing which
which appears to be somewhat slapped
together if you've watched any of the
videos
um if you've got a if you've got a rapid
depressurization if you've got a whole
breach if you've got any issues with
that I mean it's it's lights out very
very quick for the record from USA Today
they lost contact about an hour and 45
minutes okay hour 45. so close to I
think they were going about two hours
down and so so you're several thousands
13 thousand feet uh it was going to take
them to thirteen thousand feet thirteen
thousand is where the Titanic is three
fourths of the way down or so it looks
like that so you're most of the way down
that is that is deeper than active
um most submarines operate so like your
your typical uh military submarine is
deeper than that that's deeper than most
biologic so your whales um you're
talking maybe uh this that's your deep
sea fish environment
um you know obviously there's questions
about giant squid but typically you're
not finding much
um large mental life or any large
biological life that's going to be down
that far and I think Judge Jeanine
actually talked on it today on Fox I
think she was talking about it um where
uh I guess the reason why there's so
many people like there's an uptick on
people visiting the Titanic because I
guess they're giving it like another 10
years before it completely just
disappears like due to you know
corrosion or whatever it might be so
they're talking about how there's going
to be like uh I don't know maybe it was
uh they're trying to pump out as much
money doing this because what is it like
250 000
I wish I had you know but I probably
wouldn't spend it on uh that personally
given to a charity for Peter that's
about the same amount yeah no seriously
and um uh but uh I wonder what this is
gonna do now you know like people are
gonna be like dude I don't want to get
lost down there you know because my
PlayStation controller disconnected if
anything positive ever were to come out
of this it could be the understanding of
the risk involved with taking one of
these submersibles Down Under that deep
yeah look and I actually I had the
opportunity to do a ride along in a Navy
sub once out of um out of Kings Bay
Georgia and when you're down and this is
this is something that I think people
like you they watch movies like you know
The Little Mermaid you know
um you know why don't they send the
Ariel
um no and um
and you know it's not like that down
there you you go down below the
thermocline you go down below sunlight
can only get so far right on because the
salt blocks it right so you eventually
get to a point where the the thickness
of the salt blocks air blocks light from
becoming coming down the air changes Etc
and so uh you know they say other
portholes on the sub well no because you
can't see anything and then even with uh
super bright you know how gun lights Etc
that how halogen lights you're not going
to see much further than like your hand
in front of your face that's outside of
the sub because of the salt density the
light doesn't travel far outside all of
that so I mean you can get and that's
that's why this footage whenever you do
see footage like the James Cameron
footage Etc of the Titanic you're only
seeing like very you know close so close
yeah photos because or video footage
because the light just can't travel that
far with that pressure and with the
salinity of the water yeah
um it's it's really remarkable the fact
that human beings have been able to go
to such depth the fact that we've been
able to engineer crafts that are capable
of bringing people to the bottom of the
ocean safely and then all the way back
up obviously the construction of such a
craft has to be done in an unbelievably
cautious way with every single detail
paid close attention to and it's
possible that this is a case of that not
having been done you know Tim you
mentioned that it looked a little bit
slapped together on the other hand I
don't know maybe this thing was
perfectly well constructed something
came uh out of the way and hit it I'm
curious if you have any more expertise
on that like how how frequently does
this kind of thing happen with a craft
which is I mean not necessarily hit it
but was Swept Away by a current or
something else happened I guess my
question is how how
um often does it happen where a
well-made sturdy craft that it was
constructed safely disappears underwater
like this it's not it's not often at all
that being said mini subs are in general
they're they're viewed as kind of death
traps by a lot of people in the Navy
um I I don't know too many Navy guys
that have submarine experience or even
Navy divers that would do this on a
regular basis without something that was
very well taken care of that being said
I mean even Navy Seals others they just
don't they're not they're not doing
stuff like this for fun they're using
and they're operating at much shallower
depth than this but uh we are getting
into the last one minute so I don't want
to deny the super chats that are in here
by the way I do see one of the users I'm
not going to say it but someone actually
uh knows the Navy unit that poso was a
member or well deployed in at one point
actually two points in a sense uh when
he was in the uh when he was in the Navy
so pretty cool so represent represent
mu5 represent me five well that's all we
need to say about that so let's go in
there sir if you want to highlight the
ones that we want to get into here let's
go through so the West is becoming more
authoritative uh oh yeah who it is this
is coming from uh I'm not your buddy guy
I love what we usually oh that's the
that's the I'm not sure okay is that the
name I'm not your buddy guy the West I
thought another comment the West is
becoming more authoritarian by the day
at what point are we no different than
China the future seems Bleak to me as a
Canadian look uh you know we we talk
about China and we say oh China 10 years
ago would say can you believe China's
Banning people from the internet can you
believe China's locking up people
because of what they said on the
internet look at them they're crazy
they're authoritarian they're socialist
can you believe China is stopping people
from making purchases online because of
their online activity
and now look at us yeah well when that
happens in in China you know it's we
call it tyrannical and rightly so when
it happens in the United States we say
build your own platform exactly they're
a private company they do whatever they
want what what I will argue is people
need to start realizing that we're at
wartime right now this is the largest
scale spiritual attack whatever you want
to call it on the United States we need
to understand is that uh you know you
can you can let go of your libertarian
uh meme of Live and Let Live it's really
rule or be ruled in times of War it's
rule or be ruled everyone believes in
something whether it's religion God
government whatever it is those that
believe their ideas are better than
yours are gonna fight tooth and nail to
impose those authorities over you as we
have clearly seen in the last three
years you gotta
Authority can only be fought with
authority man you know and and I was a
Libertarian 2019 2018 I'm like yeah sure
who cares man you know this is a dude
2023 being on the front lines of Los
Angeles like I said man there's no
political movement that firmly grasps my
my beliefs and what I think needs to be
done in America I hear that so much
where people are saying that you know
they wanted to do the Live and Let Live
thing and then just realize that the
other side isn't willing to do that and
if they're not willing to do that then
then suddenly you have to change your
way of thinking because wait wait a
minute you actually care about my family
and our choices what do you do next
let's go to the next one of these um uh
Ian says I think the AI just won a live
deep fake I don't know what they're
talking about I have no clue what
they're talking about here obviously I'm
not a deep fake I'm live that's how I'm
reading you uh let's go Matthew Rue says
I hope Tim gets better and we see him
soon been missing his wonderful Voice
this week Tim is great Tim's on
assignment right now uh Tim's taking
care of some special operations
hopefully uh hopefully maybe being able
to help those guys down the Titan we'll
find out we'll find out what Tim's up to
when Tim Prime returns true with that uh
let's go with this guy here
uh Raymond g Stanley Jr a very strange
comment Jack welcome to the hosting of
IRL I have no idea who that is it Is
Well Done excellent show tonight did you
feel at home in this in the seat spin
that by Pillow button well look you know
I I assume you're referring to Jack was
so big the no no no no he's doing like
the bind thing come on jackets
everyone's doing it
when we talk about the pillow he's not
talking about my pillow promo code yeah
the affordable the rhetorical Jack
healthy way to not only get the best
night's sleep in the whole wide world
but also increase your testosterone over
time as you increase your sleep studies
show that you can double if you double
your sleep if you're getting four hours
if you're getting uh five hours as some
people are if you double that you can
increase the amount of your testosterone
it's just out there I'm just saying
sounds like a conservative system what
do we have next Matthew Matthew and of
course that's why that's why the left
calls themselves woke
I must have been I must have been
totally wrong because I assumed that he
was referring to the the handsome and
Brilliant host of human events
definitely brilliant I don't know about
it yeah I kind of where are we going
next George where are we going let's go
right here Matthew Schneider imagine if
Hunter Biden were black he'd definitely
be going to jail for 15 years well
wasn't there that artist that actually
was black and he ended up getting three
years in prison for the same there was
like a article today that said that also
on the board of barisma
look look it was an artist same charges
and you ended up getting three years you
can go through you can go through a list
after list after list of people that
have been charged with the who have
committed the same crime and then gotten
nowhere near the same sentence and again
your level of surprise at this story is
directly correlated to your level of
paying attention if you've been paying
attention if you're a listener of this
show or any of the shows that we all do
then I you shouldn't be surprised you
shouldn't be surprised at all because
that is what part of the movie we are in
we are very close to the third act
Showdown we are very close to the the
climax the de Newmont whatever you want
to call it uh this will be the final
showdown that's going to be November 4
2024. um this is not you know this is
not some early right as you said you
know oh Live and Let Live you know let's
just dialogue it out you know yeah it's
funny because somebody in the camera's
like yeah buddy I'm not going to let you
rule cool you don't understand how
Authority works I gotta read this I
gotta read this next one grafty just
gifted 10 Tim cast IRL memberships
that's what we're talking about wow
that's huge huge man timcast.com click
join us you have to sign up look we're
gonna have a very spicy chat about a
certain comment that President Biden
made today about uh f-16s the Second
Amendment I think he said F-15 too
which are essentially retired yeah
that's right but he's essentially
retired yeah basically so it doesn't
make sense that this is look look we
we're going to get into some of the
logistics of his statement which a weird
look we were talking beforehand I said
look this is the kind of conversation
that's going to get us into the YouTube
Red Zone pretty quick so you need to be
a member in order to sign it uh in order
to listen and oh by the way if you've
been a member for six months if you have
that 25 tier and additionally you can
then call in and we're going to be
taking calls as well I also want to
mention this with Biden his comments he
said that the Second Amendment does not
protect your right to own a Canon or did
not protect the right to own a cannon
that is literally not true that is that
is actually not true there was a
merchant who wrote a letter to one of
the founders asking if it was legal for
him to have cannons on his private ship
and they said yes which was something
that happened at that time in fact the
original United States Navy was
essentially just uh privateers who had
Merchant ships that had cannons in order
to defend themselves against the Navy
against piracy et cetera Etc uh they
were sort of um they were basically
drafted into service but they were still
privately owned vessels and the idea
being that after the war they would go
back to being privately owned vessels
yeah all right let's go next where are
we going uh mutt Nunya says you know
you're the first Californian I've ever
heard talk like me and dig his heels in
and say this is my home I'm not going
anywhere gold countries got some
stubborn old roots that won't leave I
hear you there you go yeah man I mean
again everyone has their own story to
tell everyone has their family to think
about I I agree and I just think that at
least for mainstream conservatives
Christians it shouldn't be the first
thing we think about
um it should be Last Resort you've done
every you've exhausted all avenues you
know if you want to move you gotta you
know go buy a home somewhere by all
means but to me like I'm there I'm in a
fight I'm using discernment of God I
feel like he's put him in the front
lines uh eventually what I want to do
and I'm talking to you guys about this I
want to do something similar to this but
in Los Angeles so we can have uh that
Charming young man Jack was soybeck from
human events come on over to Los Angeles
and after Like a Prayer walk we can go
ahead and and talk to some folks you
know so
um we need this we need this uh not just
in areas like this or or Texas or red
States we need this in deep blue States
so that we can also have candidates on
and we can talk local politics and we
can tell people what you can do to get
active maybe if Sheamus isn't busy
sleeping in is my pillow he'll actually
show up this time listen I had other
commitments I made in you know as the as
the the Spanish would say a woman who
prays uh all day but burns the soup may
be half an angel but she's half a devil
too yeah
have to do your duties first wow you
have to do your duties first the
Abuelita Outreach
what do we have next
um and from Sterling Wilson III Anthony
as a California Bay area native you are
absolutely right we need to stay and
fight for our states as a country and
you just lost in it um to take back
these United States right on yeah we're
getting a lot of a lot of comments like
that that just say they totally agree
with you awesome thank you and you know
one of the comments just real quick I
said good don't come to Texas bro I
don't want I don't want to have to you
know like I love California why would I
leave nice beaches for like a complete
Flatline what do you what do you think
about the what do you think about the
idea of potentially
um uh splitting California up what would
you what would you say about that well
here's the thing like if you look at a
map of California so first and foremost
I know I talk about deep blue but only
because I'm in Los Angeles area there's
no such thing as blue States uh there
are all red States and we have blue
areas
there's like one exception or two
Illinois is like the perfect example of
that as far as yeah right because you
have you have yeah you have Cook County
where Chicago is and then the rest of
the state is bright red yeah and um you
know but you were we were talking about
cities earlier like where now it's like
oh now it's most major cities like I
remember like maybe over a decade ago
people from Texas would be like this
would never happen in Houston this would
never happen in Dallas and then you had
all these tech companies move out of
California because of tax burdens or
whatever now they're in Texas and now
it's the cities now it's happening in
Houston earlier we were talking about uh
the Temple of Satan they're happening on
they're having unbaptisms in deep red
Texas my my brother in Christ who's in
Texas I don't want to come to Texas
because you guys are very complacent you
guys have a uh Texas a majority
Republican legislature and you guys are
allowing the Temple of Satan to roam
freely in your cities well now the
conservatives have moved from this isn't
happening in our cities now they're
saying like well sure it's happening in
our cities but let them try this in
front of them it's not going to happen
let me read this comment from from kid
truck 91 50 Super Chat big one and um I
want to throw this in for for Sheamus
because it's something that we haven't
talked about yet tonight he says look uh
he or she had actually what's it just
says kid
um look I think it's important for us on
the right not to ignore the actual
problem with what Trump did I like him
but it does look like he was making
either dumb or bad decisions the
transcript of him talking about the
documents is rather damning Sheamus what
would you say to that
um I guess I I have to look into that a
bit more deeply my understanding is that
the president of the United States has
the authority to declassify these kinds
of documents and we know that Biden had
documents stored which he obtained as
vice president and during his time in
the Senate so even if you want to argue
that Trump was doing something nefarious
the reality is what Biden did was
clearly worse because he actually didn't
have any executive authority to do so so
if Trump is up to something sketchy uh
it it looks to me like it's something
sketchy that he did legally but it's
it's also possible I haven't looked into
this deeply enough so I'm happy to to
look at those transcripts and I will be
happy to come back on air and let you
know if I think I was wrong about that
but you know I'll turn it over to you
Tim well so so Brett Baird uh asked
Trump about this in his in his response
and Brit Hume said is said Trump's and
this was so funny because Brahim goes oh
his his response was incomprehensible
um and incoherent and I said okay well
let me listen to it and I said I go and
look and he said well the reason that he
said number one they were the documents
that Trump trump said that the documents
he was talking about in that were
magazine clippings newspaper clippings
that he was holding and waving up
because you could apparently on this
transcript of the tape which they won't
release right which is like already kind
of you know quite like that's a little
sketchy to begin with that you're you're
indicting a guy based on a tape that we
can't listen to that you claim to have
heard and yet we aren't allowed to hear
it but you tell us that you have a
transcript uh because how many times
does it happen before with the doj the
government will come out with some claim
and then defense lawyers get to it and
they hack away at it and they hack away
at it and then eventually we get
information that says oh wait a minute
and and Trump is saying here he's
already making the claim and you can
argue whether or not that it's a good
idea to do this but he's litigating this
um before it gets to a court of law he's
going on national TV and he's made that
decision which is right as an American
obviously to defend yourself in public
before you get to the courtroom uh every
lawyer will tell you not to do that but
at the same time you know those lawyers
never became a billionaire in the
president United States and so um for
him to say look these were newspaper
clippings magazine clippings why didn't
I give the boxes back because I had
personal records in there personal
records that they didn't have the right
to have back because their money said he
had closed in there other things again
when you look at those boxes and we
talked about this already those were
boxes that were just him packing up his
office right so everything that you have
in an office there's some of your stuff
there's personal stuff there's mementos
gifts that people give you that doesn't
necessarily mean that everything in
those boxes fell under this and so the
idea is that he should have just oh I
didn't turn them all over because well
why should he those are hits yeah well
I'd also like to revise what I said to
some extent because I get the feeling
after having said all of that that it's
probably unsatisfactory to the caller
because I invoked with Joe bidend when
he was simply asking me to acknowledge
the wrong doing with what Trump did so
what I'll say is even striking all of
that if Trump did break the law here
then of course that was wrong and your
point is that something really bad could
have happened here and we should
acknowledge that it's bad well it would
have been really bad if he had colluded
with the Russian government to subvert
American democracy as well but we now
know that claim was totally bogus so I
don't know why I should trust the same
plan
that the Durham report and the Durham
hearing is going on telling us that the
government lied that the same Department
of the same government lied for all
these years we should just turn around
and accept everything they say at face
value exactly so I'm saying I think they
have an extremely high burden of proof I
would even say an extraordinarily High
burden of proof because when they've
gone after him in the past they've
turned out to be completely wrong
despite making extremely confident
claims about claims about their
certainty that he had broken the law and
that they were going to arrest him and
so I would say that
I am inclined to not believe any of what
they're saying and I'm going to need to
see really extremely strong evidence and
absolute Smoking Gun I'm gonna need to
see that he was caught red-handed doing
something illegal or nefarious here in
order to believe that that's actually
what took place we also we have a chat
another 50 chat in Amos Moses he says
unpopular opinion uh I'm assuming this
is responding to uh the hunter Biden
situation he says using crack isn't a
disqualifier for owning a gun the right
of the people shall not be infringed the
founding fathers knew of drugs and
alcohol but didn't mention it uh Jim
cast IRL uh featuring shame Sheamus they
didn't mention crack I guess yeah well
they didn't have crap I mean I I think
this they didn't have a crack because
the CIA hadn't invented it yet exactly
exactly
um what I'll say is this I do think that
uh smoking crack disqualifies one from
firearm ownership and part of the reason
I will say that is because what the
founders said and what they understood
is that in order for the Constitution to
be an even remotely sustainable
framework for governing a population
they have to be a virtuous population so
the idea that we can trust everyone to
own firearms does make sense when no
one's smoking crack okay but when you
have crackheads running around you
either have to say oh we don't have a
population that's virtuous enough to own
guns responsibly or well or we should
let people own guns but not the people
who are smoking crack well you know what
they did back then was opium
yeah and but I I guess I would say if
someone was running around smoking opium
the local Authority was probably going
to tell that person either not to keep
their guns or they might tell them they
might keep an extra eye on them right so
you didn't have the same oversight by
the way federal government legal in the
states yeah yeah exactly so you didn't
have the same like Federal oversight but
if you if you look at how things were
being done in any of the like colonies
or States yeah there was local law
enforcement and if someone was smoking
opium and also had a firearm or was
using their firearm while smoking it
that would be dealt with by local
authorities I wanna I wanna read it
almost here for that I want to read a
couple here uh some people are talking
about promo code Tanya which is
ridiculous because it doesn't exist but
actually hold on search there's a few
here of uh former submariners who are
coming in um you know one of two this is
from David aramond former Submariner
sonar Tech the only chance of finding
them with a chance of being alive would
be to use bottom mapping sonar this is
rare Tech that is not going to be on
station quickly that's right his second
half is which he paid twice to be able
to get two chats in right on there are
other options for searching with active
sonar from a fast attack sub however at
000 feet only a few vessels can get that
deep none of them are equipped for
Rescue and Salvage that's exactly right
and I was having the same exact uh
thought but I I think it's right it's
it's we we have Tech but we don't have
Tech on the right platforms the speed
the time none of it fits look folks it's
been an incredible uh first time out of
the box here myself Tim 2.0 will of
course promote uh human events
humanevents.com make sure you go check
that out 2 P.M every day tpaction.com
you want to check it out guys let's go
around shout out your stuff
uh yeah once again thanks to everyone
here uh for having me Tim pool thank you
so much great conversation honored to be
here man yeah honestly and again no hate
man like I None of the stuff that I
brought up it's just a different
mentality out in California I guess
being on the front lines and stuff like
that but um uh if you guys want to
follow me I go by inform with Anthony
um I what I do is I do stuff in English
and Spanish we've been uh flipping
districts we've been flipping school
boards uh we flipped a uh one District
that hadn't been flip Blue from Blue to
Red since 1998. I get down at the local
level we have a lot of activism I'm part
of the Los Angeles young Republicans
we're doing ballot Harvest uh training
we're getting into the churches uh
that's actually an initiative that we're
pushing a lot is start getting the
ballot boxes at the um at the churches
and so again all handles at inform with
Anthony including YouTube I do a Daily
Show Monday to Friday and Texans if you
really want me come and get me there
baby uh I'm Seamus Coughlin what I would
like to shout out today is something
that a number of you probably have heard
me say if you've been seeing me on
podcasts lately or following me on
Twitter but there's a family at my
church and they have a three-year-old
little son named Seamus and he has
skeletal dysplasia and he's having a
very dangerous surgery in the near
future so what I'm asking for people to
do is pray for him and um to pray for
his family and I posted the prayer that
his family is going to be praying I can
post it again in the the comments
section of this video if you guys want
to look at that and say the the same
prayer that all of us are saying but
please send your prayers out to him and
his family thank you Seamus thanks man
amen um and the same to the people on
board the submersible the Titan prayer
for these people because sometimes you
just look in the right place I had a
great time tonight that was really fun
and I felt like it was getting hot at
points we were talking about God and
religion and that's a good thing I like
that kind of that kind of almost too
close to the Sun kind of mentality
because we got to get up there to see
what's real see what's happening down
below Jack you're out there somewhere
Jack vasovic ladies and gentlemen
mypillow.com promo code Pozo that's
p-o-s-o and uh I want a special shout
out to Tim Poole who's out there in the
Etho verse Somewhere listening and
loving and having a great night Tim I
love you man Tim is really he's actually
traveling the Multiverse right now
that's why Tim 2.0 is here Tim Prime is
traveling the Multiverse he will be back
with spider powers very shortly
um look folks it's been great night got
to see you by the way I have to say this
I got to see the world premiere DC
premiere of sound of Freedom last night
Jim Caviezel Tim Ballard I understand
there's um there's some talk about
getting them on Tim cast look
hardest show I've ever watched in my
life
um I have my rosary in my pocket at one
point Tanya turns to me and she she
thought I was talking to her she thought
I was saying something to her I I was
just praying the rosary because I didn't
know what else to do some of the stuff
they show
these are little kids yeah this this is
real so go to angel.com human events get
the tickets I'm gonna say right now
support this movie but I'm gonna tell
you right now that
um this movie is not for the faint of
heart this is a movie that some people
are going to want to turn off I almost
want I wanted to walk out at times not
because it was poorly made it was a
fantastic the production was incredible
the quality was incredible but because
of the content and because I have two
little boys at home Who and the very
first thing I did when I got home was
was walk up to them and just hold them
and and just give them a kiss on the
forehead and say Daddy loves you because
they show
um a little boy and a little girl being
kidnapped and what happens to them after
they are kidnapped by sex traffickers in
South America and it is pure evil but
God Bless the people
um Eduardo verastegi for making this
film uh CPAC for holding the premiere at
Museum of the Bible it was fantastic
really incredible um also just a shout
out for back home um I've talked before
and Tim has talked about how you know I
had this this great Community back home
when I was growing up a town a real town
and I remember you know my dad used to
my dad worked at local hospital on
Fridays he'd pick up his actual payroll
we would go and drop it off at the local
bank at the branch and then we'd stop in
to the paint shop because the paint shop
was right next door to the bank and my
dad's best friend would work at the
paint shop and if we need to paint
something at the house we'd go we'd go
see Mike and Mike would you know Mix us
up some paint and would get for him and
he'd show us the color and we'd make
sure it was the one my mom wanted you
know and um and he passed away today
very suddenly and so just uh just were
praying for his family but it's also it
made me think about how those
communities those tight-knit communities
that we used to have in this country are
few and far between and my children
don't have communities like that anymore
where they're friends with the people
that I grew up being friends with and
that my father was being friends with
and so those that is what was taken from
from me personally that were taken from
my children this is what it's been taken
from us as a nation so let's pray for
that that we can return for it and folks
you know never forget what they took
from us speaking of community man we got
one badass mother over here to my right
oh yeah I almost forgot myself uh what's
up it was a good one I totally hear you
man as someone who lived in La for some
years before I came out here it is the
front lines there's a lot going on there
and uh
I think that people will often give up
hope when you're in a place like LA
because it's hard not to look around you
especially as I'm sure you know that
like great like Skid Row is all over
like the downtown area it's not just
Sixth Street anymore it's the entire
entire downtown of Los Angeles
um but you guys can't give a pope
there's always something better to do
there's always a future that you can
work towards don't blackmail yourself
just work for what you know the world
can be be the change you wish to see in
the world
um I'm search.com follow me on Twitter
I'm ready to go to the after show
remember we are on the after show uh
it'll be coming up at like 10 10 maybe
10 15. I have to use the loose we're
gonna take a break but we are going to
be talking about Joe Biden and his
comments about f-16s or 15s or whichever
ones that he wants and the use of them
on the American people you need to get
in there timcast.com will be taking your
calls in just a couple minutes also
we're going to be talking about the flat
earth right of course yes